all right and I'm live Bacchus what's up
man oh you know happy birthday to my
wife out there so happy way to kinda you
know spend some time with her but yeah
look at the morning I made her breakfast
though so I know you saw that breakfast
was fantastic
I'm coming old bill it's a long drive it
might be cold when you get here but you
know well he bought the old man you're
going down man you're making us look bad
out here man oh I look fantastic
hey thanks I mean I tried it's like I've
done it like once before I actually was
trying to find a different type of bread
but I found him like a big piece of just
a brioche loaf and then just really
thick pieces so it's almost like a
square and then stuff to it basically
just like strawberries and sugar like
kind of mixed together so they make that
like you know kind of a strawberry sauce
and then put that in cream cheese and
mix that up and so put that inside give
it a good old you know french toast dip
and fried good to go oh you got a dad so
sighs man I'm telling you that's that's
the new career Manley my to do a full
pocket flashpoint like 50 we'd have to
be in the same place eating all the food
I created week has been a busy and you
know in New York New Jersey damn AC
broke man so I'm hurting it's like so
warning in advance if kognito has to
leave the set because i have to take a
phone call for some guys with deliver my
AC tomorrow I can't miss that because
they might try to hit me with that you
have to wait two weeks and I cannot
suffer in this heat without an AC so
yeah for some reason if you drop don't
worry I'll keep us going and he was
going man I'll jump right back in so
well guys if you're living under a rock
or just don't
attention to destiny news at all Game
Informer exploded this week with their
yeah full month coverage of dusty 2
forsaken so the full article out there
which is going to be kind of our main
topic for the day we're not gonna go
over everything because there's some
pieces we want to leave out if you guys
want to read we may cover Matt later
dates cover some specific topics from
that one and then just a quick brief
overview of this week at Bungie and then
I'm sure we'll get off on some tangents
because this article is full of stuff so
yeah so much so to get started in case
you guys didn't know future work hold
pulled out the first victory for
definitely Italy no I'm nine months
right
salute to the skin gang salute today to
the faction where you can get the free
Wi-Fi and a lot a salute to those dudes
they got the coefficients and you got
that comfy bubble chair yeah you're
gonna live life from their management
left like the like see me years it's
about time but not that's good to see
they nene t1 i was surprising went on
this long we knew we knew in the
beginning the whole new monarchy colors
that was the whole thing begin let's
keep it real I'm saying look everybody
loved them shaders so then you know they
forced the action with that catalyst the
next week we did orbit so you figure it
was time you figure this was the week
future walk all had if they wasn't gonna
do it now man I don't know when he's
gonna go so shout out to those dudes man
that was a good one sunshine catalyst
yeah so statistic wise if you want to go
over that real quick it's kind of
interesting actually but let me know
your thoughts on those it's kind of
interesting I mean pretty much it was
like percentage of what cried players
was dead orbit 41 percent so they got
the highest pledge but then as far as
like percentage of total faction ranks
earned was actually you know our future
walk also I don't know the vibe I did
for me yeah there's a lot of people
either you know they pledged to dead
orbit and then like I'm gonna say they
were slacking cuz 42 percent to 37 still
close you name but they definitely
wasn't working hard to switch Wilco and
turning a minute so that's the
discrepancy that I see what do you think
about that whole you know as far as the
earned faction ranks versus the
percentage of players pledge players
yeah I mean I think there was and it
kind of makes sense honestly you've got
dead orbit was your first big one
because everyone wanted that catalyst
first last time it was like 70 was huge
you're the people hey what if you didn't
finish that orbit well you had to punch
it again cuz you can't switch but they
still want that graviton Lance catalyst
so I think that was the piece where you
have more players than you have faction
totals because some people might have
been 60 70 80 percent of the way there
got the catalyst and stopped yeah exam
future war cult was the hardcore trying
to grind out me like you me and a few
others 50 levels in the week and spend
the crazy ten hours or whatever it takes
to do that me for a solo person yeah
best thing that I found honestly it's
like and I tried some other stuff I done
eat easy and a few other things by
myself with a linear fusion rifle that
Titan 5 yeah yeah just be ogre because
either way and it usually worked out now
again this is one of my frustrations and
they actually explained this last time
so I can be level 33 to get the full
armor set level 33 I was like are you
kidding yeah yeah so I was like that's
just and the last time it's 37 so I'm
like two-thirds all the way through and
then I finally get my set bonuses in the
last part yeah I grinded that out a bit
easier but you know I actually have my
new monarchy set so I could just start
this next round with a full one so bass
and yeah you know I was gonna say also
then I can work on those ornaments
throughout the entire week while I play
not just afterwards cuz yeah that's
absolutely shadow could it do in the
chat regular me crap strolling in get a
lot of fun stuff to talk about man we
are excited morning Lords you know as
unlucky as you with um with get over I
got the full set fairly early like I
would say my like package 13 so I
thought maybe something you have like
poke bear look like it was something
they do with orangey like behind the
scenes to kind of boost it so I was able
to get you know that which could a
little renowned boost and for me like
since I was gonna attempt
solo but then a couple of my clan mates
are on Java the demon shot the revos
they've got a system on e d0 like
they've got it down
it's like public event like they even
call like they got names for different
things that's part of the sequence it's
like it's like yeah it's like public
event they go ah Kelly and it's
basically that fallen guy that comes out
the closet they got it need for the van
they're like random van or whatever then
we go kill him and we just get it and
then we go down underneath the church to
that uh which call it the one underneath
different a yeah we just go Nick bomb
that thing up kill thing get the faction
coat and rinse repeat and it's like
three man cycle like we just tagged him
another person so we was getting them
pretty quick man I'll definitely
definitely recommend that system if you
have a group but I agree with you Titan
way to go solo linear fusion rifle or
sleeper you know blast e ogre get to the
back maybe actually what I ended up
switching to about halfway through that
was Darcy nice yeah I was like I just
locked on him seriously like if I can go
one clip and light him up probably just
as quick and I have 23 bullets so I'm
like miss for some reason now Darcy was
actually crushing it to just lock on
seven shots he's down and that's kind of
a thing about some of those there's so
many like chunk like chunks of the lost
sector where it's like broken into four
different areas so if like me I run
through that's a risk that one I open
the door and if you got three people
it's gonna be down even faster that's
great it's orangey it feels like on
patrols but it did seem a consistent one
to where if I would be on the rig mm-hmm
and I got the Patrol that would send me
to the other side was usually the time
where you stand there I would literally
have one of those up every time and the
ones handler said it was a public event
run to the other side that has the thing
where I stand there and then you know go
back to the last sector and do it and
it's so close that none of nothing and
there's very far that's healing so I was
like if you had three people I would
honestly still wager bet that Titan with
three could still be even quicker but
probably neither but it's trust me it's
nice to break up the monotony so yes I
didn't do what he's saying would uh he
said it was easy-peasy was he easy for
him as well with the full year with the
full facts are on you get
extra renown and see here's the thing
that we was going in to the which
College of the law sector like we just
keep it going like we don't necessarily
wait for five as soon as we got four
then we going so we go on either for
packages for me for now five or now
flora now just to keep the the sequence
and I agree but yeah I gotta try your
tighten strategy what a group I see how
that goes to yeah I became be curious
how it compares but I mean either one of
those are the two because I mean if you
look for because that one there's one
good long sucker on Titan you know that
one's always there etz between the
public events there's usually lost
sector not too far if you go to randomly
I think it was I Oh last week for the
flash point but if you're on there and
you're in the wrong place for a public
there's like only two or three lost
sectors in the whole damn planet like I
was I was impossible there's nothing for
like ages there's like two or three in
the whole place the whole place I'm like
they're they're not evenly built so
that's just the thing to take in
consideration unfortunately we're gonna
find the most efficient way to do this
stuff so and even like I tweeted
esoteric he did he did the nightfall
with five renown that's just crazy he's
insane yeah just nuts but on the other
side he only got seven tokens which he
was like okay the Saudis the strike and
like that I can understand that strikes
are still debt but that's part of the
problem he's like I kind of it's sudden
somebody was like well you know he did
it for a challenge for himself I'm like
cool okay that's separate if he
challenged himself that's beast mode
totally cool if I do a nightfall if I do
a strike it should be more than yeah we
talked about it last night at last time
so what smells like I was so ticked when
I played crucible for a second I lost
and I got to it was like alright this
sucks
looks like I'm I didn't even want to do
the daily challenge when it was
crucibles like I'll just go back and do
Titan Twitter yeah then I agree like I
said hopefully like I said what the next
one they will work on those other
activities like we discuss and get that
up so it's an even claim especially like
you said the rate like those those
things have da
yeah they're doing renowned with night
falls you'd have to start on like either
pyramid what was the nightfall that
sounds like because something where
you're public enough you have to go find
a public event
they do a Lhasa okay just do a public
event maybe a patrol do all that stuff
then go do your night falls like cheese
that's that's crazy we know they need a
little work
man if you heard fireteam jet man oh
yeah Destin ligerian he was disgusted I
get it I just no listen like I said I we
talked about getting last 5:20 just air
on it's not a caution on completely
removing grind but I do agree it needs
to be tweaked it needs to be a little
bit more fun and harder activities need
to be one way to a couple different
other things so it's not just this one
grind it's like well sectors it's like
okay they're only so much fun just yet
mix it up that's having quit that's the
common thing everybody wants just other
activities to be equal so uh so Guardian
cone is coming up guys if you've not
heard what's where we met
so that's right with the Guardians
number two listen this year but you know
maybe next year if things get back but
Guardian comes so big at least I feel
like from what I've heard because I was
even listen to Guardian radio they're
like man it was feeling like it wasn't
gonna be that Destiny related because he
was on the downturn man it was when they
start announcing it they started
investing to psyche I was like I got it
there was you know you were go in
initially and it was it was a tough call
so I just said you know what I did I did
pax already I needed a break I needed a
push I'll take I lost 83 I played gambit
so it's less incentive for me you know I
mean the gap it's amazing for the people
we're gonna get try for the first time
know that one I wish and there's
probably not everybody's even gonna get
a chance to but we'll see if you're
gonna card econ have fun say hi to this
new team should be a good time forget
what else is going like fortnight I know
is gonna be there yeah oh yeah have a
good time at least destiny is gonna be a
viable part of it now I think with
Bungie be in there which is cool I think
Bungie actually being part of this like
officially in an official capacity
he is kind of surprising because they
first didn't wanted to be called like
destiny Khan for whatever reason they
had to change the name and now they're
involved so there's some shift happening
there where they've got a little more
say about things which is so nice nice
so we're gonna cover this here and like
after we finished up the twelve game a
forum article it exploded there's so
much stuff out there if you even aren't
you know a Gamestop person go by the one
episode go by the peace go into a game
stop pick up the magazine whatever you
do find your son
yeah I still want to even go get a
physical copy just have it I'm gonna
have the digital but you don't want the
physical yeah yeah it's like one of
those I have an old one for it might be
taking I forget which one
whatever the couple big releases it's a
big one so there's a lot of stuff
working to get to in a sec before we get
there they do have a couple changes
coming for the raid prestige layer so
July 17th patch 1.2.3 is coming with the
prestige now as they said prestige is
going to be no changes to the actual
gameplay itself no mechanic changes to
the fights you just have specific load
outs but everybody kind of threw a fit
and was like hey for one if you download
faster you're gonna give a jump on it
and two they're doing they had them both
at the same exact time so two things
they're giving you an hour after release
for eater of worlds 11 and then 24 hours
after release so 23 after eater of
worlds for spire the stars now people
know that mechanics I was just gonna be
managing the timing of fly gear or
understanding what the weapons are in
the load-out and they tell us what one
of the model the first weeks modifier is
brand new it's called arsenal yes we're
all I'll say about it it's hard curated
loadout goes they'll give you one thing
told us baby
yeah it's gonna say it's pulse rifles so
that's gonna be involved I was gonna say
where is time-worn
is that kinetic or is that both are
kinetic cuz basically all the winners
busy is almost the same the crucible
version of the hammer inspire yeah I
used to rock those guns heavy so I know
what under those two
yeah so time-worn kinetic pulse so pulse
will be kinetic so get with that one I
mean in that field you've got decent
options yeah it's gonna be curious what
else they pair you know in a power slot
and the energy slot so yeah I'm
interested like you could not do I guess
you couldn't if you're rough yeah I
wouldn't say you couldn't who knows what
they'll do before we run out of time for
that
otherwise for crucible coming up this
weekend starting here in not that long
actually about four hours
couple hours baby Valerie any crucible
you play this weekend since there's it's
a victory week there's not too much else
going on valores 3x4 all that playlist
now this doesn't include everything
coming with the patch so doesn't include
competitive this doesn't include the
other things if you see them Fowler like
number below it it counts so basically I
think this week it's mayhem which is a
fun thing to mess around in and then
you're quickly playlist but it doesn't
count
competitive won't compel an iron banner
will compel trials I won't include those
so that comes with the patch layer so
for now mayhem quick play if you want to
get your crucible taken care of you know
and you haven't done it yet it's a good
weekend to do it so absolutely I mean
I'll definitely be in him and I was
having fun with valor I'm hosting
ranking up to like the third one and
actually has some decent um what was
actually I'm doing it for a couple of my
crucible ornaments somewhat the chess
piece got the whole outfit got the
shader ready it's ready to go I just got
a lot well now we open the big can of
worms
let's go so if you guys have not read
this thing take some time there's a lot
of info in here and there will be more
if you've got a game informer comm slash
forsaken it's the hub for all the
different stuff they're gonna release
throughout the month so go there I'll
have a link in my description you can as
well click on that one check them out
they got a chance to sit down and they
don't get to go out and be like I mean
some of the community people they might
get out go out to do a capture event
they might have like an hour to they sit
down with them for like days for this
stuff so game informer always gets these
really in-depth exclusives because
they're part of Game Stop and they have
you know little wait to throw around
kind of cool they get a little more info
than the rest of us because the game
come they really do a good job I think I
really do a good job right there stuff
yeah solid yeah yeah yeah so there's
this this is just the big one right here
coming up so caveat before we get into
it we don't want to go too much into the
story right now I may give you a couple
overall arching feelings about the story
feelings about like the in-game in the
Dreaming city if you've heard about that
cool haven't it exists sorry it exists
really we don't want to go into the
actual like story as to who's involved
in what and kind of what the order of
things are but just kind of the overall
feeling of that some of the other
mechanics and stuff like that we might
get into but overall don't want to go
into like story spoilers there's not a
ton or say in this thing but we're just
gonna want to avoid those in general ah
so we'll kind of go through this one
I'll be clicking through you guys can
follow along and we'll just kind of
cover pieces quickly if I don't leave it
on the page you can always pause and
read it but if I move that fast then
there was a reason for that
basically they paired up with high Moon
Studios this is the big one
so high Moon Moon they did my
transformers game some of the best
transformers games if you're a fan of
Game Boy those are those guys you know
I'm trying to remember what the name of
that Transformers game 1 saw fall of
Cybertron Wharf Cybertron
yeah those weren't pretty cool so I
remember seeing just even the art style
was cool yeah great games so they
actually sat down they basically paired
up now did they like co-developed this
thing I don't know but I mean they
definitely got their their name on the
coat like on the title card so they did
a pretty good chunk so nice to see
Bungie getting help which for something
that's substantial and I'm gonna say it
right here and now let's go no it's what
I told you last night me I didn't think
they could pull it out by September I
had said that in previous didn't think
they could do it now do I think they can
I have hoped now as we say we're trying
to temper our expectations but it's
getting a little rough because there's a
lot
excited about knowing it's the same
thing man I'm really trying to temper
I'm trying me we've talked about this at
nauseam you know from the very beginning
with flashpoint can they turn around how
do they turn it around is September
enough time and you know with these
articles that we're about to get into a
deep dive it's just like trying to rein
in my favor employee and like together
cuz I am so excited man I am really
excited I'm really hopeful but uh let's
get it to a better kitchen No so yeah hi
movin they sat down they decided you
know things they wanted to make they
want to get back to the hobby they
wanted to have a name world which is
cool we'll get to the ideas behind that
and honestly one of the biggest pieces
it's the enemies get started the enemies
that we fight are different now this is
the story stuff this page breaking out
there's a bit about the story kind of
the ideas you go through and what's
going on there and things that may or
may not be happening but I don't go in
too much in detail on that one cool
thing about the story though is there's
probably and this is a guess there's
some opening there's a middle section
which is not linear and then they kind
of will funnel you to an ending but it's
the first time it's not just like do
mission one then mission 2 then mission
3 there's not a direct line there's like
a kind of an opening in the base let's
kind of do it at your own order so like
yeah I like you know I mean it's not
like forced marriage but you can kind of
track with things Jerome mmm-hmm yeah so
that's actually pretty cool
and the other pieces from what we know
from reading some of this is the fact
that the campaign is a build and a lead
towards like the end game and towards
the rain so as you do things through the
story as you pay attention to the lore
and the story of what's going on that is
building and give you hints as to what's
to come in the in-game what's to come in
the raid you know as it leads to
something possibly more so just the fact
that that's building shout out the Lord
addict yes that's a happy man hopefully
and that's a happy man right there
because
that's all he wanted and again shout to
do is make some good point everyone's
like yeah we're hoping that this law of
things in the right direction and I
don't tell them dude in it in a chair is
that I'm confident because again you
know testing community summit thing you
know Milan got in it shout the myelin
games I know everybody wants by if and
you know we all want to buy but whatever
reason they chose Milan and mile is good
man people don't give myelin games
enough credit and one thing we you know
we talked about about a bunch of five
points ago he went in there and I love
the spreadsheet and he said listen
where's the law guy in this summit you
know and the next day they had to bring
the guy in and then he had his almost
like his list of demands but like why
are not despise the story not be a
medically tied to the rate he broke down
why the taken King was good because
everything mattered it was a sequence
you did the campaign it led to an
overarching story and what I'm seeing
now is the effects again I don't know if
this is directly milan right now but i
am quick but yet i probably a little
quit for all this to be violent but at
the end of the day him be in there and
we know hopes winners on the gameplay
side and all that other stuff but him
being there even if like i'm confident
that even if they it was ahead of time
but if they weren't they say they went
astray often making a stupid law
decision with him there now it'll get
scratched
i'm very confident because that was the
vibe of the community summit when they
went in there and they were talking
about forsaken things that they
initially had planned and those guys
were like no if you did this and they
were like okay let's pack this up we'll
reconvene tomorrow all right what about
this based on your new feedback that you
guys give me any coming they loved it so
that's why i got my chest out a little
bit that's what i'm confident will or
just a little bit just overall you know
saying because they're more flexible
than listening to what we want and I
think addict will be happy hopefully
based on this new direction yeah I mean
it sounds like this is a good step and
then if this is their direction going
forward big like this is where they've
turned the ship finally four story
connections I mean that was kind of
thing we
crow to get introduced in dark below and
then we had our little offshoot of House
of House of wolves and its thing but
when it came back full circle for taking
king like okay I could see like those
two kind of be in a thing and then we
come back for the big you know Big Daddy
Betty and he comes into play and the
fact that it just even connected to
different expansions the hive escalated
we had the taking we had him he was
there like that growth all the way
through it he was the small raid guy and
then he like went off and then you
fought him later in the end and
everybody had that fall down moment when
he steps up and he's like the size of
the Empire State Building like those
moments were really cool because that
was those moments where you're like okay
this has been building to this entire
thing and it's taken like a year and a
half to get there absolutely no I mean
Cade being involved sorry if you haven't
seen Kate haven't seen that then you
have been living under a rock yeah make
it but the fact that like that's a
character we've gotten unknown like
little bits here and there over for
years now yeah and now we gotta say
goodbye for a reason so yeah we're all
gonna be pretty motivated on this one so
that one's pretty cool but the enemies
shout out to politest he had a decent
little article he's like one thing
that's probably not been saying enough
is the fact that the enemies some people
I go they just kind of look like only
skin before they're different every
single one of them has different
mechanics different feels to them it's
not just like oh here's a high of with
some snow on his back a little dusting
of white on their back I mean okay so
when the cursed are all exploded yeah
you were chilled whoo it was overall
very very minimal it was the premium
enemy experience that's one thing we've
been waiting on and we we need that like
it's for years I mean the takin was kind
of a thing but those while they actually
had some different mechanics I gave
something that the whole slitting scions
I still hate those two bite to this day
when you're doing those things solo Cod
they pissed me off but like they needed
a read they need something like that
felt different and these really really
do yes they're gonna be late they look
like Frank
Stein reanimated fallen I mean there's a
look and feel to them may feel fallen
what everything it was definitely gonna
feel different like when you see Voigt
saw blades that are crazy
you've got yeah the three different
types of totems if it's arc it's gonna
stun you if it's a boy I can't even
remember the three right now I remember
looking through it well yeah arc totems
rubber bands because you can't get away
void creates a shield so you can't
damage the enemies solder is spinning
turrets of fire I'm like that's a
mechanic that's like no yeah absolutely
and what I like overall if we caught the
podcast when they were forming what they
talked about was just an overall
aggressiveness of the end that to me is
important like they're behaving
different you know because for the most
part you know falling iike ball up pop
their little shots you know I mean and I
was very high with them maybe the Cabal
dogs you know they're not after you
after you like I get a sense of
aggression and that's what these guys
are pulling off so it that makes the
gameplay different and I like that
absolutely because I mean yeah they were
like cabal high you know every captain
every high-ranking whoever life they all
do and it's so annoying be more
aggressive and not so weird I mean
they're reanimated zombies they
apparently don't have as much of a
conscience so just the fact that if
they're pushing a little more that I
can't wait man hi so the enemy types are
a legit thing to read about so look in
the details in here
I mean curse trolls with a bigger
explosion I mean so think of that that's
gonna be like your scream they're like
little spider things you've got the
workers they carry a small shield and
it's it blocked shots until you hit them
in the leg so differently that's argued
the lurkers or the Ravagers there's a
hunchback skulkers who charged at first
sight spinning the lantern like sensors
that slam into the ground creating
solar flame so their Lantern I think is
actually heard like their weak point as
they said in the podcast so yes usually
if actually have to hit this little
moving target that's going around like
they're definitely gonna be different
different feel different
just bit look Cole I mean look at the
cool and I guess what I'll talk about
like I just liked it they look cool they
look different and I know we're gonna
give you the bearings later buddy even
them you know it just is just a really
cool complete redesign of an enemy and
then lore wise they're supporting it by
saying that these guys been through you
know really reanimated messing with all
type of sorcery and things on the dark
side they probably should be you know
and I love it man it feels new that's
what that's what definitely needed you
know instead of always the regrinding of
old assets we got these these new bad
boys out here and just a whole you know
the whole atmosphere of the game you
know it sounds for the cool thing yep so
anyway types legit what's on the next
page again we're not trying to go ultra
deep this is the idea now this might be
one of the Barrens on this picture
honestly but yeah I think these might
actually be some of the Barrens but
that's he's got a bigger version of it
but that's that lantern and that's an
escalated version of it but these guys
are gonna be definitely a force to be
reckoned with all these interns at a
different article I know this is a quick
click through but these are kind of a
nonlinear section of the campaign you've
got basically a specific type of fight
for each one of these so not the same so
next so obviously we gotta talk about
this supers yes let's get to it
let's have not seen have not heard I
haven't done a video on it but this is
probably the best one because they're
all here now so who of what classes you
want man I'll let you take your like
whoa the coded command all the minutes
this stuff sounds super exciting so what
is stopping time right coded a commander
Sentinel you know same sort of melees
cause explosions or void ability damage
also attack
just avoid detonator and subsequent
damage cause the data to go off and
attack detonators to enemies caught in
the explosion
grenade energy harshly be charged
blabbing so if you get one like group of
enemies with that detonator you just
kill them all
yeah you know I'm saying it but that's
insane and then you get that recharge
then you get the banner shield which
being useful offense so pretty much like
the Titans in front he's that moving
shield you know defense but what's cool
is the your your partner's can shoot
through that so it's almost like pushing
through that's like the visual eye game
right
have you played overwatch the exact turn
up straight up it's like everybody get
behind captain America
you know he's got a shield up but you
can shoot that's gonna be cool and very
I can see like a lot of scenarios that
could be really effective of just like
you know even like boss DPS or just
trying to get through very difficult
areas you know I'm even taking like raid
mechanics like that that's gonna have a
lot of functionality so that sounds cool
then we have um sunbreaker code of the
Devastator you know say and we saw this
in action work from the first vid och
right where was the the Titan hammer but
the one that it's so huge and they'd
like you throw it any kind of stage so
pretty much you throw your hammer with
the melee button it remains in the world
risk retrieving it when it fell to a
fluid charging ability triggers health
regen very underrated then the more solo
a bit solar ability kills you get a
higher damage up to three times and then
increase that mall that hits like
earthquake and leaves to innate ohms
behind and one thing that's cool about
the the articles how they have that
fantasy section so for the seminal title
they're like if you use an accord in
command it's like you got your shield
don't worry my friends I have my shield
and then with this one it's like I be
the frontline crush the frontline move
the frontline with that idea that's
really cool though I didn't even catch
it before about if you throw your hammer
so we that's the four again solar now
somebody else actually has a thrown
projectile melee so it's one of those
things in a PvP situation say you're
like lunch punch and they back away and
you chunk your hammer you might die but
you might get the kill - so like I was
new way I always enjoyed those throwing
knife moment
but this is the I didn't even catch this
before risk retrieving it so if you
chunk it far away and you run out and
pick it up you literally have your melee
ability good to go again that's sick
that's crazy that's like going to run
and pick up your arrows for a bow like
if you shoot four of those and they drop
on the ground and you pick them up you
get your handle back that's actually a
really cool mechanic like that's a
different thing that I haven't felt
before just be nice if they did that for
the throwing knife too but maybe maybe
they will no fire tornadoes seriously
that doesn't say yes so go to the next
what else we can't what else we got from
a striker the calvess just straight up
what it is you can describe this code of
the missile not even messing around so
when you're airborne melee to slam into
the ground like a bunker buster and gain
super energy for your trouble so if
you're up in the air floating around got
some enemies just hit your melee slam
down that's cool it's actually a nice
little big crush as opposed to just like
I haven't try and land in this mess I'm
just gonna smash down instead if you
pick up him a while sliding you
automatically reload your equipped
weapons so apparently I'm gonna need
some knee pads gonna need to invest oh
yeah and reloading you're equipped
weapon and increase weapon damage for a
short time so yeah sliding all the time
and this is one of those where if
sliding is a thing hopefully there's a
mod or a perk or something that helps
that as well maybe yeah under crash
since you hurdling great distances like
a missile to hit a targeted area like a
meteor strike now granted this is like a
direct Abul fist of havoc but the last
whoever writes this article by the way
shoutout just the way you put that into
words I wish I had words like that that
adversity yeah since you hurdling great
distances like a missile to hit its
target in a meteor strike like words are
words are an important thing but they
are it just sounds like you but the nice
thing is in the podcast they said you
literally control it for you control it
yeah they said like yes so that's cool
can they aim it out direct it out and
then you kind of finish your arc and go
busting in so that one sounds kind of
awesome to smell worry as we go through
these
they sound like they're putting all the
other three to shame yes they'd like
every one of these sounds better than
its counterpart so is the other side
getting buffed I think that's not out to
Chris Cole really we talked about it
earlier and um I'm confident because if
I remember when taken King came out you
know and um you know obviously had some
record a be of stone color sunbreaker
and Night Stalker they did make
adjustments to the other classes to make
them competitive so they know that
there's these new attunement so we're
just waiting Cole like everybody's gonna
want to wrap grab these so I'm confident
that they're gonna bungees history has
shown me that when they introduce new
subclasses and things like that they
always buff up the other one because
they know everyone's let me playing the
new stuff for a while just to get a feel
and then you know to bring it to level
or to add more functionality certain
things that week so I'm confident was
and then also remember this if you
caught the podcast they did say how they
lose a game form that they're staggering
these are two minutes we're not getting
all of them as the Forsaken and I don't
have a oh oh no I was gonna say do you
think if it's staggered do you think
it's related to dreaming city yes that's
why I think it's gonna be like a Laura
thing and either they discover the new
thing you know or you know discover the
new ability a two-minute that way that's
what I'm thinking I mean it people gonna
make complain and say hey their time got
gating content I get it
you know I'm saying shout didn't do he
say he's a little worried that other
supers will flap to the wayside trust me
I hate you to do yeah you do but I still
think they're gonna bump them but um
ultimately with the two minutes that
they're gonna stagger out I think
they're gonna do it once but I said
every week the city changes didn't he
say something that every two weeks or
something like that what was one with
the time for him you remember uh it was
like three weeks bring me all right now
that's I've heard I feel like I've heard
kind of conflicting ideas behind that I
don't know it's the first three weeks
things are going to change in that
Dreaming city or if it's a rotation of
three weeks is what I thought they said
in the podcast yeah
actually yeah because I honestly wonder
like if it's just one time like one two
three and then it's done and it stays at
the new one then the purify god it's
like a evolving thing though like the
vibe I got is that this it's like it
goes from one state to the next state
into another state and it may eventually
will and maybe you don't say but um and
Petra moves around you know for my
understanding yeah
yeah so Lucy but uh yeah it's gonna be
interesting see how that that's handled
with the a too much but we got more to
mitigate so here I'll give you a rundown
says on the subclasses right now there
are two diamonds on the right at the top
and bottom of the screen so as you guys
know you pick you two different trees
we're search essentially inserting a
third one so I have a third option to
pick from will probably deliver three on
day one and have the others take a
little bit longer than players are used
to imagine one week one or two weeks
before you can even earn the next batch
so they will all be available on day one
which is cool for especially like if
there's a raid race or thing things you
may not have the most efficient
efficient way at first like as you're
saying the big shield shield they may
want to say that for the final drop
because that's a game changer BB and
it's huge
yeah it's huge let me get into this too
the locks out there way brosé alright so
the new attack atomic reach melee
ability creates a void explosion at
range while holding the grenade button
down creates a short range area
explosion supernova that sounds cool
again what was right in this shadow did
is do like give him a raise
so ain't got any void ability kills now
heals you and grant ability energy so
it's almost like a spin on devourer
right devourer get the heal but any but
you get a little ability energy for that
synergy and it says Nova warp
empowers you to a chance
dimension-hopping abilities letting you
repeatedly tell what short this is and
then erupt
the earth of energy fantasy you are
Nightcrawler I got some evil thoughts
already first of all the synergy with
the you know recharging your healing and
stuff like that I figure it's not gonna
be a full heal like devourer I'm gonna
be a bits and pieces here but still
enough to me the ability energy is more
important but the thing I'm thinking
about that I already got my mind working
for PvP I'm thinking about like dudes
across the map you know how to get team
shot all the time yeah one of the cool
things about storm trance was that
teleport the ionic blink so I can link
went get to you right the only thing it
wasn't no explodes now I'm talking about
raising these are sensual teleporting
blinks to get me in the near up if I can
just go into where a team of three or
four is that's going to be scary and
just bold explore
yeah I mean think about banner fall if
you could like beer in the tunnel and
they're all sitting at be you go
blink-blink-blink again if you can do a
fast enough boom like you can't move
that fast to get away from it because it
was quick it was like blink blink boom I
mean there's no major delay to it so
that was really really cool do I'm
already thinking of like the strategies
well it's gonna be sick so that's that
you know say let's get it let me get
into l1 then we got o
a torment of control for the storm call
this don't call right now as a week yeah
I got my violin music out right now um
so let's see what they doing anyone tap
the belly button to fling a long
distance electricity ball that
eventually detonates and flings a
lightning bolt straight downward I just
got to see how that works how that looks
that's gonna that's gonna be interesting
our kills sometimes create ionic traces
a spark of raw arm energy that travels
across the ground toward you which we
can can be collected to recharge a
Billie's that's that's that's sick it's
almost like orbs of light like almost
like a master work thing going on yeah
then you got chaos from each fires a
long-range blue be it of intent and
focused BAM
now here's the key which can be
deactivated early to say anything so
that I like say yeah jump on set like
there's a medium level guy and you're
like I hate holding on to my super cuz
I'm not gonna because I just gonna lose
it all because I don't need it
completely ok melt the sky real quick ok
I'll get it back fairly soon that's
smart
fantasy someone's been watching Dragon
Ball Z oh here you go
let's do it Toby's that coffee cup
thrown up what that is
absolutely yo that is gonna be sitting
at the key I want to see how much DPS
you can do the bosses like single-target
bosses that's the key but also was dope
is that you can stop it you don't have
to go use your entire bar on it that's
gonna be a cool strategy and I gotta be
greedy and take the third lock right now
here we go don't play torment of grace
you hit at the door grace melee attacks
burned bad guys but empower allies
transform your grenade by holding the
button into a blessing a projectile that
heals allies and drops retrievable
overshoot orbs that's a that's that's
like full support stuff round like big
that's awesome yeah we get into a
support role and then this actually
actually this class I play with I played
with this class at e3 during gambit
so this well of Radiance is cool slam
the solar sword into the ground you
create a wide areas and let me spray me
on this it's not like a rift this thing
is big you can put six Guardians in this
this little circle this rod ratings that
they're talking about so it's giving you
the healing and it's giving basically
hitting rift and an empowering rift in
one and I'll tell you right now and it
also says not this part I didn't notice
is it also in house region your non
super ability so it's a fantasy just
because you're a cleric doesn't mean you
don't still like wrecking food so it's
pretty cool
complete support class which I like
something different you know I almost
like a witch go was to tighten um the
old-school bubble in a way but yeah done
shoot out yeah and it's pretty cool I
really I'm really liking that whole
healing people and throwing the things
towards them and
that's gonna be pretty cool so I'm
excited about this from a pure support
class I like to do tuning that so i'ma
let you get into the hiatus
now but I'm most impressed just to go
back to a healing grenade yeah they
haven't even done anything remotely in
the idea of like it's the you know the
Trinity okay
healer DPS they haven't even touched any
of those until right now
and this is like this is a a small
glimmer of hope that I may eventually
get my world of warcraft' cuz like now
here's the thing as I say to hear and
think about this you've actually got
somebody who can make an a bubble like a
dome of like healing and empowerment
then you take a Titan and you go drop
that shield wall that you can shoot
through so you're protected on the front
from say a boss so you can have guys
from the site taking care of one or two
you got four dump and damage into the
boss you're not getting touched you're
hittin stronger and I'm not seeing
really a downside here except ooh now
this is one of those points
who the hell is ever gonna go use a ward
of dawn the bubbled now if you have a
shield wall that you can shoot through
like so that's the point of what I'm
saying those other supers they've got to
look at them and I don't know if a quick
like but you say hey I have a shield
wall I can shoot through most of this
game is in front of me except for a few
random spots why would I ever use water
felt like that was that tree would need
to stay where you going I understand you
got listen I am one thing about the
sandbox team I got a shout out with new
skiing boys they are good about stuff
like this
I'm telling there's never been a time I
can think when a new subclass or some
new ability and they didn't go back
there very good we always complain about
the winning or that launcher they'll go
back like oh this is long I'm confident
you put in the book because I don't
think this will be launched you don't
think that the old set of things are
gonna the old subclasses are mean like
like done enough to make like a
difference they catch up to some of
these like Titan Sentinel like I mean
yeah you can throw it but honestly like
if you're gonna Sentinel there's no
reason you wouldn't do this one
absolutely I'm telling you they're gonna
go away from a balance standpoint they
know that
can't leave it the way it was waiting
for those patch notes this will be an
internal bet between me and you you know
when launcher forsaking comes out there
will my bet is there will definitely be
a day when we're gonna get that sandbox
notes is gonna be a big sandbox joint
it'll be like the day before release
they're gonna let you know when they go
before four-second goes like oh by the
way this is what we're doing with our
stuff I'm telling they own it fair
enough
all right you're up you can fix your
audio lord dude you can it's it's good
now hunters are up yeah okay so Night
Stalker and this is the actual picture
you're seeing on screen so way of the
Reta way of the Wraith mainly smokebomb
heavily damages and slows those in its
path that still sounds the same so I
don't know if it's much I mean you're
already pretty messed up if you get
touched by that thing anyways I don't
know how that one's gonna be much
different
it just says heavily damages and slows
it already kind of messes you up in PvP
a lot so I'm not sure how much more it's
going to do so yeah we'll see nail the
perfect precision kill against a foe to
vanishing game true sight okay that's
insane that's insane and some precision
kill again and you go vanish mm-hmm and
what is true sight see through walls or
they put a little X on them and yeah but
if you killed them what are you looking
at I don't know how it's gonna be
interesting to see how they they display
in only as far as the UI but my
impression is like I said it's almost
like that Night Stalker thing when you
know he puts two he marks everybody you
know what so I mean I'm assuming listen
look how that's gonna be so easy to proc
they're not easy that is the proc you
always I just get a precision kill
that's crazy yeah seriously
goodie it says it's weapon perks um yeah
I don't know if it's like the scope I
don't know love to know what that is
legacy so what is your super spectral
blades drops you into a veil of shadows
so gonna be harder to see maybe not
completely invisible but like I'll be
[ __ ] kind of really cool if you once
they send it realm like
honking just slip behind foes and stab
them before they know you're even there
so fantasy is assassin to strong Lord
seriously go invisible pop your thing go
into the shadow world and go stab people
in the back don't rip up rip him up with
your void swords like that's cool no
void is definitely I mean void you've
got your support with your tether lock
him down hold them up split the damage
this is complete flip for void which is
nice which is nice offense for boss ants
baby that's good so gunslinger way of a
thousand cuts
yeah trick knife trick melees fling out
a fan of burning blades I don't know how
far that goes but that's just the melee
yeah in turn killing burning enemies
recharges your knife trick and burning
enemies also recharge your dodge
knowing that people are sleeping I could
think of loops right there yeah
blade brush so doubles down on your
knife skills and expels a volley of
explosive knives now I can picture this
in a couple different waves do you think
it's one where you throw a lot do you
throw like a wave in front of you and
they explode like but if it's like if
it's a to compare to a Golden Gun mm-hmm
this has to be pretty substantial has to
be it has mean how many knives how big
of explosions like what are you thinking
I remember when we saw the initial
Vidocq of this class it was about four
to five if I can remember him but I'm
not melee or is that the super now cuz
it's good boy fan of burning blades like
yeah that's a good point you're right
because they did say burning blaze if it
did look like blade type projectiles
interested well know that one until we
get our hands on it nobody messes with
way of a thousand cuts because Danny
Trejo a desperado
good job fools all over the place I'd be
kind of one of those where I wish like
you popped your super and you
like say you had like 20 knives that
maybe didn't get quite as hard but you
just like doot-doot doot-doot and you
start throwing them all over the place
dropping a bunch of little guys throwing
like six into a night drops on the other
tendon to a boss like I was getting to
shout out to bloody knuckles I was
getting to an argue with him cuz he's
like in this whole you know hunters get
screwed all the time kind of thing and I
get it to some extent you know saying
but it was I'm like do I think cuz what
is he's getting caught up with the
flashiness of what warlock in titan are
getting right and I get it but in my
opinion what we're reading we're gonna
do way to current.next
these this is pure functionality like
this is you're gonna get precision kills
all the time with you know I'm saying
the way of the race right
my trick melees you kill and you get you
recharging your trip back into burning
and you're gonna get these things more
frequently to me then the other
abilities of the other two nice any
other two are not cool and you can't get
any type of synergies going on there but
to me I feel a hunter is probably the
more practical of the three that's just
my opinion based on what I mean
whichever pain cuz you you're the hunter
you tell me how you see uh I'm kind of
you on that one
like all these things seem to be and
this is why I was like this is why I
want to know what's happening with the
others because all these are described
to be no they're just they're working
together so well like you know all these
things kind of have a feel it's not just
like I have a punch with a little extra
void void shot on it I have a little
later like it doesn't feel great and
this stuff sounds awesome like just the
distinction between the two seems can
announce right now solos contam Ark
Strider way of the current so slide
before a mailing to unleash a powerful
uppercut that's cool see that happened
just like yeah backs oh man so that and
any mainly hits increase your reload
speed so if you do uppercut them maybe
they're staggered maybe you got a reload
BAM go knock somebody in the face
stagger them say you punch a knight in
the face he's staggering for a second
reload your submachine gun go dump a
clip into them mm-hmm all all of your
arc abilities electrify your enemies Wow
like that see that's the things like
people now
you know the trees don't sound like that
right and subsequent melee strikes
disorient them and refuel your abilities
and everything is refueling your
abilities yeah everybody synergy with
them Oh
so use your staff like a normal like
normal if desired which is mob dog but
it's like I wish there was some other
tweak to it yeah and this is where
bloody stole my cuz he won I guess he
did wanted this to be an original kind
of super and I get that I agree with but
it probably should have gave it an
original thing like because the other
ones do win just the staff like okay
where's my difference yeah I agree I
agree but this second part but the
whirlwind guard means that you can guard
by spending your staff reflecting back
projectiles and tripling your staffs
damage afterwards oh how long does that
last do Fleck shoot stuff back first of
all we gotta test out what a new
whirlwind avoid what how many hammers
can i bounce back like I want to know
you know what that sounds like remember
when rods of iron came out and they had
them little remember them the medallions
what would they call it there was one
that allowed you to reflect back a super
I don't know for a rat aghast one of
them ones the sword the block with the
sword yeah it sounds like it did not it
doesn't sound like they're restricting
anything so we saw in the Vedic when he
did that pole twirl anything that was
shooting was getting thrown back yeah we
gotta see like I know you know all shout
out to Fallout play all these guys will
be put this to the test
yeah yeah what works how many shots can
you oh how much higher back like
seriously that is gonna be kind of nuts
this this has tremendous and then finish
off what else you can do after you you
blocked every day yeah and then after
you reflect for now this is the where
the timing and the length of the super
is my question
yeah and again you might be wearing
radiant flux forever now thanks
reflecting back it triples your staff
damage afterwards so say you're trying
to creep up close to it
I really hope some of these enemies and
barons and stuff they aren't just like
I'm big so I smash the ground I am so
tired of that yeah it's like get
creative do other things those one I
forget who did it the shadow thief
panics he was the only one who actually
would not slam the ground mm-hmm
so I wish more would do that Darth Maul
has some amazing amazing exactly so I
mean complete spinning and it's like but
you spin it you get close and then you
turn her in and do a triple shot with
yet thing a couple times just to finish
it up it's like damn like this is a lot
more for PDP the implications are huge
with what you can guard if you hear
somebody pop a super and you got a team
behind you just rotate this thing throw
it all back at them and then they can
just turn around and slow them down and
see just it's like guard guard and like
3x shot so I mean it's all of these
sounds so much cooler than what we oh
man could you imagine worm husk with
Night Stalker you'd never be able to see
a person who never I think you know what
y'all forgetting - rocking rat King with
the invisibility in that whole synergy
also with that class as well that's
gonna be crazy and um don't you guys you
have like some other exotics I know that
kind of do a sidearm box after get off
top but um - this so much synergy that's
gonna happen with that anything I am I
said you never you building with the
guys the thing I'm curious about the the
last one was the way of current in again
me being a PvP got that is scary
the [ __ ] coming at you doing that
block thing and you can't shoot him and
he gets to the crew and triple damage to
get a good like that's an aggressive
hunter like you can't touch me you can't
touch me bond and then you run doom
think I could see things already in the
crucible that's going to change the game
you know I'm saying they were already
elusive would aux right and stuff like
that so if they still have that
elusiveness with this ability you know
it's gonna hurt so so yeah if slightly
and this is what we're like trying to
temper my expectations yeah all I'm
gonna want to do is play with the new
super so of course I'm going to play the
crap out of this game yeah hunter master
race man and dude I go lie to you way of
the current and um the first way of the
race those are very tempting I'm not
gonna lie those are very thousand cuts
to know what's going yeah there's a lot
of questions and not saying that that is
not dope but I agree with you we just
got to see the effectiveness but those
two for me personally had me super
excited about cuz I can't even lie can't
even I gotta give it up so the lawless
frontier we've got the tangled chore yes
now the cool thing is this is one of the
two areas we get with this expansion so
it's not just one it's not just a
dreadnought it's not just a little mini
circle on Mercury we get to legit places
and the endgame space they said is
necessary can use your sparrow on not
thank you no more no more Osiris the big
circle that called the sack of doom yeah
seriously that was late hands with the
dreaming city there's like the cool like
elf Lord of the Rings city but there's
an underground mmm-hmm
so there's a lot of space in this
expansion alone much less reusing other
areas and stuff but yes um so tangled
sure this is basically the reef if you
guys would imagine the outskirts of the
reef there's a whole bunch of crap just
smashed together you've got land masses
and ships and things just out there
asteroids all this stuff just shoved
together just stuck together with
bridges honestly this sounds cool fits
the reef and we finally get to explore
the reef we only got to go to a social
space we never actually got to see this
place I'm right
very much so
you're kind of vendor basically is going
to be a fallen mm-hmm so it's basically
it's a fallen mob that once held you
know Yelp sway over the tangled Shore
but basically now that all this
craziness is going on he's kind of just
a contact that's holding down his own
little fort so he is one of those that
is going to be kind of cool just cuz the
fact that we're dealing straight-up with
a fallen guy like that's our that's our
vendor every other vendor is human every
single I mean human awoken their
guardians are like but not a completely
enemy race guy that's kind of I mean
yeah barracks is basically very close
and I'm very curious yeah I'm very
because that ultimately said we're gonna
find out in the triumph stuff Laura yeah
we'll get to the bearings in a little
while because that's what looks like
some of this is actually talking about
Baron hunson a little bit but like look
at the look at just the scale of the
barons
they're they're legit and whatever is
happening there looks awesome by the way
to think like in my opinion the Barons
look so cool they could have been the
raid yeah what I'm saying like the black
van eight an eight boss raid against the
although all the Barons that would be
sick that would be sick so I think you
know I'm saying like this is this is
really really tremendous I like where
this is going I liked it the Russia um
so on a random offshoot who do get to a
point where they start talking about the
weapon slots we've talked about it
before the biggest thing it sounds like
they're probably gonna have issues with
is the ammo and they may even have to
play with it for a little while and
tweak that is just the animal balancing
so if you have you know a kinetic sniper
and it uses the green type ammo and
you've got an energy thing if they both
use the same ammo then that's where
you're gonna be like looking for those
bricks no my only issue with this is
take the damn juggler things out if if
it's already gonna be hard enough and
you want to have some freedom how you
play don't put that like fake juggler
mechanic that's out there 66% of the day
like take that [ __ ] off of excuse me but
the facts to run around and be like oh
I've been using my hand cannon for a
while I'm almost out of ammo I switched
the one gun and I shoot like one enemy
in like three bricks pop out and I'm
like seriously this podcast mature this
I'll be jealous the bow from what I keep
seeing in footage and stuff like that
did you get to you have to use it right
I got news about before always look
forward to that yeah Mo's awesome
because it's it's it's a scale weapon
but what I like about it is like I said
when you ho I use the exotic one and
when you hold down and you get those
precision kills and you get that
explosion and it's a big radius like
it's it's pretty forgiving you can
really get a lot of multi kills with it
and it's powerful it takes a lot of
damage off of enemies when you hold it
down so you have functionality with it
um you can't hold it forever when you
jump it in like only time I try to hold
on yes yeah now you have at once it gets
maximum at a certain point it has to
release and I mean put on it's really
powerful and it what you think it's just
like a skillful it's like sniper and
linear fusion rifle had a baby it's just
it's just unique figure to it but it
feels good that's one thing about Bungie
they have weapons down and like it feels
good you would think is there like a
ball like this ain't gonna work no it
works I was using that man I had shotgun
and kinetic I had bull in the energy and
whatever it's called now and then power
I was just messing around we don't you
see if they got buff they were not lost
so that was a mistake I should use a
rocket
Wow but I'm not bows bows legitimate
what was the jet yeah so I mean honestly
outside of just watching everybody's
game play with that thing just can't
wait to get my hands on it but I mean
the whole energy saucin I mean three
shotguns you're gonna be fighting for
ammo so it's like it's weird for them to
say hey yeah you can use three shotguns
but what if you only have like 21 bolts
between all of them what's the point
like yeah and that's where I need to
under
and how they're gonna balance this thing
out are there gonna be kinetic shotguns
that use its own kinetic ammo and then a
shotgun and the energy slot that can use
its own so you're not fighting quite as
bad over it
that's the ammo issue that I've got to
see so it's like in concept and that was
one of the things they said before and
we'll get I'll skip the Q&A section of
the article but just gonna briefly hit
it but it's like okay so they had the
big question the d2 weapon system
flat-out it didn't work yeah they admit
it but they didn't want to just revert
back to what was in destiny one I mean
yeah people enjoyed it but they're like
we want to evolve and that's one thing I
know destiny too got a whole bunch of
crap and I'm probably gonna get some for
even saying that but they are trying to
change any of all this game not just
have decimate a point 6 to point 7
inches have the same crap so was the
thing that change they made right no and
I think they even know that now whatever
testing they did they thought it might
have been ok a lot of people probably
could have told you that beforehand but
they're opening up and they're learning
um but this is a way to take if you want
to go you know scout rifle shotgun
rocket launcher just like d1 you
straight up Ken there should be not an
issue but with this freedom they've
evolved and I think this is one of the
silver linings for what they've done for
destiny in destiny too they made
mistakes but seizing with exotics and
catalysts the evolution of what they
screwed up and therefore had to take it
something to improve on it but not just
resort back it has been better like
exotic catalysts have been amazing
oh it would have ever come out if
exotics didn't need the help they didn't
feel cool let me let me see from my hand
I recognize your good did we Pat myself
on the back
I told he buzzes forsaken wouldn't
matter if war mine didn't attract warm I
tie like I know we all had the money in
the bank for forsaken but we gotta give
warm on credit people are coming to pack
back to play destiny because of those
big exotic changes because of the
masterworks because of escalation
protocol because it occur because of the
faction rallies now you should I'm
saying like I knew warm on had to be
good
cuz you gotta get that excitement going
it's like I'm part of the marketing team
I see the vision is it I knew okay look
we can't do everything we want right now
let's give them this let's give them the
grind things they want let's giving
these new activities to do to keep them
occupied
we still got summer solstice solstice
and all that other stuff and now we got
the forsaken coming in the I'm telling
you man it feels it feels right but I
know I'm gonna try to keep it together
but I think I know what's going on here
and these are the changes that you
needed leading into this big deal see
but continue I mean that was just a
little tainted but that's kind of one of
those I mean EJ wolf in my chat and all
you guys it's like they've they've taken
lessons they've definitely taken their
lumps as well give they got kicked in
the nuts for destiny ones release and
then curse of Osiris while they were
down they got kicked in the face
place they got hit hard and that's why
it's like January was this like turn
somebody somewhere was just like do what
you have to do I don't care if it's talk
to the community every day tell them
what you're doing listen to him a lot
more bring him in here so we can figure
out what they really want like this
thing has to work and survive and
they've done everything in their power
so far to do that absolutely absolutely
not up to about five hundred to a
thousand people that would love to shake
hands with some day like so many awesome
people ends without a doubt people that
pour their heart into this game
absolutely absolutely you got you got to
give credit where credit is due and you
know we've said it a time and time again
you know if they could pull this thing
off it would be them but just the fact
that it's going in the right direction
just from how awful things were I mean
we were the most hardcore destiny guys
and we were pissed off and we weren't
playing so to see this thing you could
see the turnaround maybe starting to
happen if they can pull this thing off
man it's probably what desi probably
would an only get kind of like I could
do something like that right because
even d1 had the rough start it's just so
it's just a funny ride isn't it he's
gone
lucky right yeah like if you write a
history like Jason Shire here and he did
one before just put the whole history
together for us so we got it but one
year one like I mean trials basically
because when I can't even remember when
passive was launched I feel like it was
like March and we had six months or what
a long time until September came for
taking King trials kept alive but it's
like d1 we were just like you had the
etheric light' you had the leveling and
then some of the stuff didn't carry and
there were so many mistakes like it was
a mess dark below PTSD only a shout out
to the dude shout out their own postgame
Parkins because like us they were the
only guys doing destiny stuff like
everybody a man and rightfully so right
it was the dark ages in this place shout
out the businessman can feel the love
the best it feels like oh it's all man I
listen you guys to men and it's really
good to see you know this payoff for
this loyalty and I'm actually listening
so let's just let's just hope this thing
continues to go yeah so I've been
sitting on this page long enough anyway
but now long point for sure
so you got you got more of the bearings
in here I don't even it's not a planet
and it's not a moon tangled Shore it's a
float some eight jetsam uh collection
asteroids that are lashed together with
grappling hooks cables duct tape you can
look down and see the abyss of space
that just sounds cool
like literally Walker and be like
there's there's space like oh don't fall
my brother's gonna hate this by the way
because he's not a platformer type guy
nothing
so especially as I heard with what's in
the underbelly of the Dreaming city they
said a lot of platforming he's gonna
hate his life but yeah I'll pull him
through
so we've got and some of you guys may
have like watched the video like the
story trailer from Game Informer we've
got a couple new public events which
sounds kind of cool there's almost a
horde mode type one with a couple
different waves of attackers and things
like that it's called the cryo-cell so
you get different waves we're like a pod
from prison builders crashes down people
are trying to get
so you fend them off and then finally
the boss will come out so kind of a cool
concept to that one but there also looks
like at least from again people picking
apart videos and frames there looks to
be another escalation protocol type
thing coming yes that serve I was still
getting another type of mode and
according to the DG I wasn't in fun guys
they were kind of talking about it and
they um I hope this don't correct what
I'm talking about where it's kind of
like a the way they described it was
like it was like the actual area is like
almost poisonous or you know I'm saying
like you can't walk around in here was
that the underbelly of yeah maybe I'm
getting confused with it most but it's
one of these modes that it it's it's
kind of that kind of mechanic and then
bosses and you kind of have to create
your path through this like very
poisonous kind of area where you can be
killed by the actual environment and
then still have to deal with bosses and
stuff like that so yeah man it uh it
definitely sounds really cool again more
modes this is on top of gambit right
there this is really cool stuff I like
what I'm hearing is it feels taken King
issue it seems like there's going to be
a ton to do yeah I mean they can stuff
like I found the lost sectors of the
tangled Shore to be more nuanced than
most you've seen until now just actually
put like we know lost sectors need some
help so for sure there's an underground
fallen hideaway that involves a black
market fighting Green cages there's just
War beasts like I mean just the insanity
that's going on in here it's like the
fallen and the awoken and all it's so
crazy
absolutely so they got more on the new
weapon slots so just of what we got here
for one this is a new exotic if you
haven't seen it roll oh just a rule
it's basically a gun that shoots in like
multiple different directions kind of
like a mini spread yeah they defined it
as like the Contra spread gun at the
desk cool yeah so and this is where I
was saying they didn't want to they
wanted to evolve from destiny one they
didn't want to just copy it or regress
back to it so how does it work
ammo type is no longer directly tied to
weapon slots instead ammo type dictates
the power of the
and in the relative rarity of finding
that ammo type weapons using primary
white and special green ammo can either
show up in kinetic energy slot a weapon
in the power slot still uses heavy
purple ammo
I'm still gonna call it heavy ammo til
it's heavy for life
many weapon archetypes now have moved
out of the power slot so shotguns
fusions are the big ones that I can
think of yeah it looks like pretty much
we guessed it right like everything that
should be in the energy slug out of the
powers light and now into the energy
slot is fusion snipers now the only
thing I saw if when you get to I saw two
different type of grenade launchers like
the yeah and then you've got drum loads
the breech would be like your
single-shot think of fighting lion or
single action and there's some that are
single-shot as well like your uh they do
that like stunned which you can actually
use really well on shrinkers and then
you got your barrel it's like do those
your power because you can dump out a
lot more damage so it's still got the
damage potential of say a rocket if you
dump all six so there's a distinction
between those but I mean stuff that came
out of the power slot is kinetic or
energy something like Hawthorne shotgun
which is a beast anyway because it's
full auto just melts that's a kinetic
shotgun so what if you go kinetic
shotgun Uriel's gift for your auto rifle
then you have a rocket launcher so they
just give you more options where it's
not always in energy summer anymore just
kinetic that's just how that falls so
basically it only the way the way I look
at these like exotics are not going to
move right those are gonna stay for the
aussie name pretty much what they are f
heavies gonna stay where it's or if
heavy is a rocket um what else would be
oh we're getting there we will get them
going ahead get no but they just said
there's gonna be some exceptions like
right stuff may show up in a different
slot especially powerful things for
instance an especially powerful bow
might use green ammo instead of light
ammo something like legend of a korea's
is just so crazy powerful it's still a
power weapon even if it is a shotgun
just cuz yeah it melts everything it's
so they said the weapons are found in
kinetic or energy
lots are in use primary white ammo the
rifles Bo's hand cannons pulse rifle
sidearms shotguns herb Scout rifles
submachine guns mm-hmm these weapons are
found the kinetic or energy slot and use
green special ammo for each loaded
grenade launchers fusion rifles shotguns
sniper rifles and trace rifles is that
they're found in both types of slots but
they use the green a most that's kind of
like your middle level yes you got power
ammo drum loaded grenade launchers as we
were talking about right many of your
fusion rifles sleeper and then the other
two right rocket launchers and swords
well Lily if you won't be sleeper it'll
be like tarantula well I know ya touch
me but you mean those style of I don't
yes yeah I'm just saying sleepers the
best of them
basically you've got options that kind
of do what you want like it just kind of
mix everything up equipment rifling a
kinetic shot for pesky ads a solar scout
rifle for dropping the wizard shield
linear fusion rifle and your power slot
to finish them off I mean you can you
can do three shotguns say if you have
Hawthorne's say if there's an energy
shotgun in your second slot and then you
have a curious technically you good but
a curious would probably be using power
no matter what no matter what and I just
happen to get all you type is packing in
any cheeto that's gonna say that's the
nice piece is like give me a give me a
scout rifle or give me a hand cannon but
if I want to be like far range lemme go
pulse for that mid to far anything about
sniper back I want my snipers again
because it was I never know wouldn't I
never use them that much because
honestly it was rocket or none yeah like
why would you use it over those other
options and now that it's out of that
slot it doesn't have to compete with
rocket launches you know I mean it was
just so tough to have those all those it
was like six to seven different turns
all in that powers like right not a out
of that it's gonna add so much
versatility to the loadouts
you know meaning it's gonna be you're
gonna have to think smart too because
you just can't go oh I'm gonna do all
three shotguns or anything honestly like
you're gonna not you're not gonna be
able to get ammo that's the vibe I'm
you're gonna blow through ammo that's
the value like you would have to have a
real specific purpose to be like I'm
gonna be the warlock support healer
right gets close to me then I go shotgun
kill him so I stay
live like but see this is the point if
they actually get even farther into this
whole like hey I want to be a support
class hey I want to be a tank like yeah
more of that and then you can't have
crazy-ass builds like that but are gonna
give you a purpose right and I'm gonna
hang back I'm gonna be healer I'm gonna
chunk those guys from far let me get
some my armor that get my you know Gila
grenades back quicker so I'm like
helpful support and but I can protect my
butt if anybody gets near me please all
purpose you don't absolutely yes and the
thing I'm thinking about is think about
raid encounters right when you have
people who sometimes don't do the
mechanics of the raid but they kind of
hold down parts or just do things to
keep ad clearance and whatever like
that's where those guys can have those
kind of wacky loadout so to speak and
they can just specialize in doing that
for the team right it's gonna open up
it's very exciting the possibilities
that this opens up yeah I think it's
cool yeah if they don't nerf the ammo
too much that is my job mild a bit
viable to have some variety if they give
you enough options with the ammo yeah I
want to see I think you can have a lot
of fun with that yeah we just already
nervous about again because I'm the
crucible guy oh well I mean and that's
kind of the itty bit we got to see how
that's gonna go a little bit with
certain things I mean for sure I feel
you on that one yeah but didn't you have
a lot more fun PD possible one though I
mean like just the insanity even if it
is late I mean some one of my friends
still says he loves the last word
shotgun era the most people loved it but
it wasn't even use last word it was just
the fact that there was a meta you knew
those like we'll see but I mean that's
kind of those things shout out the
cactus yeah anthem it's one of those
things this the game doesn't that
doesn't have to worry about if this was
just a PvE game raids were cool and they
had could draw the line in the sand or
PvP
had some separate things to it they
always want everything to feel the same
and I'm like come on like do you have to
be able to divide and conquer so
so hopefully they can balance the two
all say I don't know well it's gonna be
hard at the end of the day it's like
what we said before when they started
making bringing sixes back and making
the recharges of the supers they went
nasty to launch with that super balanced
mentality for PvP and ultimately became
slow and unfun so even if these things
come back and it's a little chaotic at
first it to me it's better than the
alternative people find ways to get you
know I'm saying like low metas and stuff
like that at the end of the day it's
those people still having fun doing
those things even remember when I'm
prometheus lens was broken for a while
we what having fun with that matter
because it was just crazy
so at the end of the day yes there will
probably be some tweaks to certain
things but to me this is still better
than the alternative of what we had
after launching 32 which was this fake
competitive balance when you're supposed
to be this powerful guardian and let
them let people have fun you know saying
they just let people have fun so what's
the other ones that know so yeah weapons
will be interesting and it's like I'm
only gonna know until I get my hands on
it but I'm just like yeah I'm gonna go
pulse right no I can throw a fusion
rifle in here hell yeah I'm just looking
forward to that
so absolutely some things they're
honestly just gonna change when you log
in for the first time to be like claw
Thorne's is no longer in your power
slots you go check them and it's like oh
it moved
Cerberus 1 basically it's a Frankenstein
of a weapon kind of a hodgepodge
together leaving the barrels literally
all look different except the bottom two
but like that looks like one off of a
that looks like they ripped it off
another guns little mini gunshots for
directions at once now that spread is
gonna be they say contra contra spread
good ey looks like you're gonna have to
be up close and personal to pump that in
but if like a knight walks up to you
just blast them I guess with as much as
you've got it's an exotic
Auto rifle so what do you think energy
[ __ ] proxy energy
it could be kinetic shoot I don't know
it was gonna be curious why they put it
in no mm-hmm um so the dreaming city is
the big one now they don't tell us much
obviously it's the in-game area right
but the cool thing about the Dreaming
city and this is where again not spoiler
territory but we just want to cover like
the feel and themes of like ideas behind
this whole thing right when you log in
at first and you you can't even get to
the Dreaming city till you play the
campaign yeah that doesn't even get to
be an option not and also there are
things once you get to the Dreaming city
you run around and you might see
question marks that will smash you in
the face yep good which is because that
means you are not gonna be ready for and
that you have to work your way up to you
can't just like so it's patrol I can
kill everything except this strike is
harder nope there's part of the world
that's flat-out just gonna kick your
butt until you're ready for it ahna
thats how it should be so I like I've
separated this into your patrol campaign
you're normal you're in the game higher
level
go get your butt kicked own mm-hmm love
it gotta earn your way man it's a full
sized destination about the size of
necess Nessus is not small its planet
size probably is number 2 good point
good point is that space in the game
area is gonna be place like once you get
full full level the puzzles that you're
gonna find there's now how would you
describe this thing from what I've heard
isn't basically like the Lord of the
Rings elf city upper level and under
meat sounds like it's in the dark
podcast it's in the damn dark they were
talking some stuff so he guys say oh how
that works the guy reference stranger
things like the upside down I don't
that's a sick visiting like that as
that's gonna be crazy
mmm-hmm yeah so they said virtually
drawn from the pages of a classic
fantasy novel this elven homeland under
threat from insidious dragon has that in
that has infected its heart now I think
that's literally just like a reference
to like Lord of the Rings but I wonder
in the back of my mind if pipes had
exploded when he read dragon cuz oh yeah
her dragon oh yeah yeah I was like so
him sitting there just like reading the
article like I don't know if he's on the
plane or in his travels too dirty
because I know he's in the States for a
little while right now I'm better and
it's like if you just read dragon it's
like cirno hum Cara so yeah I know yeah
like that would be for one mind-blowing
if they finally actually did that but
either way I think they're just
referencing like lordlings and not
Hobbit but the other way it's like
they're gonna have some of the best the
skyboxes which they always do but it's
just it's gonna look amazing there's
like big towers they describe giant like
gigantic doors that look like what the
hell was in here tight just the feel of
the whole place but there's like two
levels to it it's gonna be huge saralyn
like the way it was like the way it
sounds it sounds so cool now the other
piece is it's dynamic and the fact that
it's gonna change week to week
yes now this is cool this is a whole
area that's not even gonna feel the same
every week may have some of the same but
I'm sorry go ahead
no was one thing let's not understate
that what was said about this area it's
probably from an artistic standpoint one
of the most beautifulest things the
bungees ever created this is quotes from
the game of former guys like they are
amazed by how this thing looks they were
saying it's it's like a testament to
like some of the best things I've ever
seen ever in destiny so that got me
excited you know just from the world
standpoint now you're talking about
evolving and you know I'm saying like
it's over is in fact we can even unlock
that until we get through the story in
the back like this they go for it man
this is the type of stuff I want to hear
I love it I love it man
yeah absolutely but yeah so changing
week to week so the idea is people are
gonna burn through that story that's
fine but the first week you go step into
the Dreaming city you're not gonna be
high enough to go smash the highest
stuff it's gonna take you a little bit
of grinding things like that but the
second week gonna be a little different
now the takin our old with the Dreaming
city they're one of the
things I don't know if their radar lated
or just like mob-related
but the taken it feels like the takin is
going to like overtake this thing over
time I don't know if it's gonna be a
continuous struggle where like week by
week it goes like you know 1 2 3 it like
climbs in the amount of taking this and
then it falls back down and fades back
and forth
I'm hoping it's on a cycle again it's
not just 1 2 3 and you're done because
that'll kind of suck if you miss it yeah
yeah um but like as taking is gonna
overstate this thing things are gonna be
different places your vendor is going to
move um hopefully we've never done that
they've never even ever moved a vendor
outside observe which he's a whole
different animal than I love that
hundred thirteen questions with him
though were Scott his little fingers on
his face I was like oh yeah this is like
you know I was like I was laughing
really
god it's a guy I think if I could take
him out for drinks I would probably just
be laughing half the time so absolutely
there is that bought that said it was
funny yeah yeah 113 questions half the
questions are ridiculous get a few
tidbits in there but overall just a fun
little place oh yeah so here's your
pictures look at this this is the
Dreaming city so we've got this like
giant Tower which I think the big towers
what they mentioned the raid is gonna be
related to yes so that'll be cool you've
got petra venj she's back we miss her
yeah base mode and then also you've got
the takin they're the ones who curse the
environment and that's the thing where
they say it's gonna change over time but
they also said this is the new tower
defense style public women got a public
event in an in-game world that's
probably also not going to be easy right
[Applause]
Luke Cash's provide offerings to take
the blind well and this is a vast
Cathedral of an arena where 3 to 6
players came from in front a new take on
a wave base fights like court of or
exceptions are calls for escalation
protocol so this might be the blind well
for the escalation protocol yeah so I'm
thinking - yeah but you're not even
gonna see that until you're at love
highest
you're not walking around them yeah you
go ahead yeah I mean literally I love it
because you know this is to me kind of
like the prelude like after to me this
is what escalation protocol kind of set
the stage for things like this I feel
yeah I like that creep wait you're not
ready yet you don't mean and you still
have to do things to get like and then
you can open up more it's just gonna add
a lot of longevity I feel I think we're
really gonna be very deep in this space
because I like the fact that certain
areas Arden that gave it off but you
just can't you're not strong enough I
love that and then just to see that
progression and now you talk about the
changes this is exciting stuff man I
didn't think they would go this hard as
far as the environment and let's be
honest it's the first time the raid area
and its own global space like that's
another whole thing to get your mind
around right we've never had that in
destiny these are really cool concepts
and I like that they're pushing
boundaries man like this this is what I
want to see that gives you that feeling
of this emerged immersive world that
people wanted from destiny would kind of
disappointed with destiny and will get
into the map stuff as we go on but
exciting stuff exciting very happy about
it
so this is water here on the periphery
of the city dropped flasks allow players
to briefly glimpse into the ascendant
realm to face vessel challenges and
travel along platforms and tunnels that
don't exist in the real world to find
secret chests right lay just the fact
other stuff you can't see you have to
get these flasks to be able to even see
the realm this literally sounds like
Oryx sent you into the other realm not
going to be in the in the upside down
like rate area stuff so I mean that's
what they've said like the dread-nots
had a lot of puzzles you had the you
know
chest of gnashing teeth and all the
craziness like the stuff you had the
seven different things you had to build
up or whatever and then you had to go
find that one opening there there were a
lot of secrets in the trip not a while
to figure out I mean you had to do that
one thing where you had to get infected
with that like hazy thing and then do
that sprint across the open again the
only way to do
that is have like a buddy like stand on
the platforms ahead of you so the jump
yeah you made it there the first time
car like that stuff was really fun to
figure out but it was nothing like that
has been in D&D to love it back to the
mystery back and in the tone like the
doc tone everything like that made taken
king great you know saying these these
are these really cool poised they kinda
expounded on yeah I mean Colonel said my
Jeff said he's like the way did you
launch they really need to give this
their all and I think they honestly have
they've given it every single thing they
can possibly trust me I'll try to keep
expectation I'm shot attempt right
fanboy doubt right now how much do you
love this game
way too much curdling clearly yeah my
head's gonna explode reading all this
stuff and we got more stuff to come
throughout the month so like this is
just them this is the big info dump so
yeah so just the fact that you can do
that type of stuff
they said the early versions the game
meant players couldn't glean their ways
and all so you can't actually find
everything you can't see everything
until later because it's gonna change in
different weeks like the ascendant realm
may be different in a second week there
are certain things you can't find the
well they won't even be available for
week one or week two and that's we're
saying like maybe it's our powers that
were able to get from here in different
weeks in different places thank you yeah
because they said it could be a week but
he said like a week or two and it's like
if it's on a weekly rotation maybe it's
just like a time game I don't know
but yeah there are certain things what
about exotic quests where you have to go
through a full three weeks cycle just to
get all the pieces like first go find
this chest take this back desert and
then we get okay is there's like okay
you'll find this you're like well crap I
can't find it somebody clearly said is
gonna go do it again and like that is
gonna be kind of crazy so this place
sounds like it's gonna be on a weekly
rotation but on a slight aside your
other milestones are on a four-day
rotation yes grow it doesn't feel like
just oh I'm done for the week your week
starts probably just probably whenever
you wanted to yeah literally
yeah my weekly reset videos are gonna be
all over the place buddy
can take me oh my god
never keep I'll try that's my only thing
though it's like I know some of you guys
enjoy ours we have our discussions and
things like that and some people just
enjoy my content but I always wonder
it's like is there a point in me doing
some of these things because I know six
other people have done it because they
don't sleep and they don't have other
jobs this is their job so if I get to it
later or I do these other things
sometimes I wonder if there's a point
but I feel like if I date a raid guide
in my style there'd still be some that
liked it I may not get that many views
but I still have my solid fan base and
same as you guys over there so it's it's
one of those so yeah it looks awesome
like that skybox I hate how awesome some
of that stuff looks like those are
disgusting to chat he said mas halls are
definitely changing to a four day cycle
yeah yeah that's crazy
yep that's uh it's later on so you got a
Q&A with Christopher Barrett yes chill
man right there just crushing it so what
does it mean to be a director he's
basically the Hays at the 30,000 foot
level has there been a shift in how your
team organizes they just want to be able
to have a clear roadmap but I think
we've seen that yes is the fact that we
see a roadmap of what's coming what
they're working on and their
communication needs like their product
managers have to work on their like
tickets but we actually as the public
get to see some of that which is kind of
bananas most of the time you don't ever
get to so that's actually really cool
dusting to there are things that
surprise you honestly they were like
they were surprised with some of the as
I said they got their their hand slapped
real hard so they learned so escalation
protocol like that was probably built
from some of the ground they probably
had the Mars space but they're like what
do we do with this he and I just want to
jump in on that that mode the modes that
they talk that kind of like mimic
escalation protocol in Forsaken if you
know what the podcast one thing that
they did say which I'm very excited
about is unlike escalation protocol
where it's so hard to kind of get that
big group together because they don't
have a proper mass mass rating system in
place they didn't say they would have
that but they did say it would be much
easier so there's something in place
yeah I'm an instant standpoint that's
gonna make us able
to do because we know gambit has full
matchmaking we aren't worried about that
but I'm talking about these other little
activities that kind of mimic corridor
vorak style things and other things
where you kind of group together in
these environments in the you know in
the city welcome city that is cool at
least the effort is being made look we
listen to your feedback on that and
we're still gonna try to put some things
in place to kind of assist with that
that's all I'm asking
yeah just a little bit just to
acknowledge that like I know sometimes
they seem hell-bent that this system has
to be the way it is now they got a
question about guided games and that
thing still sounds like a train wreck so
that doesn't seem like it's getting a
whole lot better for now but generally
they're listening to some like some
systems either they've locked him in
system at like in the code play games
someone's age but like they're trying to
change everything they can and that's I
think where you start seeing limitations
with code or the engine or systems
they've built of what can and can't
change but they're definitely trying to
change as much as they can possibly so
and there's but here I mean this is a
really good question how much community
feedback do you listen to and that's a
hard thing to do because sometimes it's
like Nintendo is Nintendo's one of the
best at this they you don't know you
don't even know you want something until
they give it to you and that's like like
breath of the wild is a prime example of
that so it was just I mean there are
certain things game developers have to
be innovative and they create things and
like they make some decisions I mean
random roles were one of those things
they want them back it's like okay but
how are they gonna do it okay they want
I mean you can't as they say you can't
develop the whole game by community
otherwise it's never gonna get done
there's no focus it's all everywhere
right but if they don't listen
you're still gonna piss off your
community so there's a balance and he
made a tremendous point that sometimes
when you see the forum's you know the
loudest guy in the room doesn't
necessarily represent the whole so I
like that point he made as well too
because he's you know this - like hey
this needs to happen and this needs to
happen and then they also have to look
at the entire feedback and see how it
affects everyone you know saying so I
like what he went into some kind of like
minds that develop
mindset things and I thought that was
pretty cool and I'm kind of breaking
things down on the decision make it's
just good to see this transparent bungee
now right we're getting to understand
why they do things the way they do them
and what's the thought process that's my
whole thing like if you make a change I
want to know your reasoning behind the
change and I feel these past four or
five months we've got that they like
look we did this because we saw XY and Z
or we're still thinking about tweaking X
Y Z we're not finished you know we're
gonna let you guys play around with it
and then you guys come back but I love
that that's how the game evolves you
know I mean Octus we're holier than that
we know more than you all these like
what uh what I forgot um knees you're
like these Bank you know block blocks of
bands and combust across the board and
nervous Augusta blah just you know I
like I like this new approach in this
that part in this article was very cool
by Christopher Barrett
yeah and it's honestly probably one of
the most refreshing things about these
last five months now some people have
stepped away and there may be harder to
win back but forsaken with everything
they've built if people do come back I
think this is gonna be that time where
like it's 40 bucks now what I need to
understand there's a side note sorry I
will get back to it I need to understand
how they're gonna sell this package yeah
how are they gonna make this thing for
people what if somebody bought curse of
Osiris was like will screw this I'm not
getting war mind yeah how are they gonna
balance the poor thing I think what its
gonna be is gonna be like Game of the
Year Edition sixty dollars so what about
somebody who like us I mean do you think
they would drop a discount on every
other previous that what if the previous
pensions were dropped a little bit say
they were ten bucks for the old ones if
you only need one so you have what about
those who bought curse of Osiris did you
say Robert rightly didn't come back for
war mine but they need more in mind to
play forsaken which I still hate by the
way that I yeah it's got it you know but
if you heard Scott Taylor his whole
thing's like look we only did it because
they asked him that initiative
rapid-fire question and I think his it
was like hey we don't want to leave
anyone else behind by them not having
the content yeah yeah yeah it got a fire
you shout the slow motion about it -
previously on see the point of a second
yeah in theory but I mean they state
what the verbage they use slow mo was
that for people who have bits and pieces
or don't have they're gonna put
something in place to make that easier
so there's gonna be something like it's
um either discount or some thing that
has the old content you know that that's
the only thing after thing cuz you're
making a valid point there are people
who just you know after customer stars
I'm done so they have to be something in
place for those dudes yeah
and that's I think the dude said it
right and that's what they've said -
there's gonna be other SKUs that come
out that have some package they're gonna
do discounts some way to get you in cuz
they're not gonna want to like you know
segment the playerbase just to screw you
over so there's gonna be some package
for those who just got destiny - didn't
get anything else yeah there's gonna be
hopefully a discount that says like hey
I've got this
I want this if you buy forsaken will
give you this other one for five or ten
bucks or something no in honestly like I
was saying this to you the other night -
mm-hmm
this is not a MMO it's not a continuous
online thing but damn if they're not
gonna give us enough content that we
have about that many hours to play out
of it yeah
asking for a thirty dollar annual pass
and 40 bucks for basically taking a base
frame of a game and revamping a living
crap out of it so completely rewrite it
know you've got seventy dollars over the
course of a year if you break that down
it's like oh I don't know five six bucks
a month I mean come on skip two cups of
coffee and you gave yourself another and
that's one of those decisions where
people have to think relatively low to
pay 30 it's $30 for a whole damn year of
a widget you know I'm widget the problem
is like I said it but where they're
gonna face is that they're gonna be
people and rightfully so that this is
their opinion they're gonna say look
we've been burned we don't trust you I'm
not paying anymore it should be free I
get it and I'm saying the problem is I I
just can't relate to that person it's
like we talked about this you know the
other night was like I look at it like
you went to
restaurant right you ordered a meal
right
you ate the entire meal and then
afterwards you were like hey this is
this wasn't that good
I'm saying you can't keep coming back
because you had that yet meal that you
didn't like either you're done at that
point you can't keep coming back and say
hey now from now on you gotta give me
every meal free because that last one
was terrible like you you ate the whole
meal whether or not you were satisfied
it's your decision to say okay you know
what I'm good I'm not going back to this
restaurant again
you know said that's where the people
who say you know like forsaken should be
free and all this that's what you know
the end of the day this is still a
business that that's all I'm saying like
people are making stuff and content and
making a king because they regardless of
how you feel about activision or
whatever that's where you know i'm
saying at the end of the you especially
did that the dues that deftly lose me is
the guys that said it and they got like
a thousand hours you can't play that
much you know hundreds of hours of
destiny and then be like y'all that you
got enjoyment you know so at some point
you you you you played the game enough
where you definitely got enjoyment out
of the game or you played it enough
where there was some level of you know
completion at that point that's it
you're in again for the next one are
you're not that's just me ran over no no
I mean absolutely and it's the point
where a lot of people seem to use and I
don't hear it as much but you hear and
sometimes like oh it's a game worth like
dollars per hour I was like okay and
it's one of those so you think you're
gonna play forsaken for 40 hours I'm
probably gonna play it for like 400 at a
minimum you got 40 hours in your first
two days just to try and burn through
and try and get up there with stuff so I
mean the amount of time that you get and
that's one of those things people don't
now if you're one of those that picks up
a campaign place there it and sets it
down I can see where that could burn you
curse of Osiris especially but what it
looks like in this one is like is this
your time to come back and try this
thing again for $40 right hundred
percent now the annual pass no one is
twisting your arm to buy that at first
are you gonna get plenty out of forsaken
yes but that Annual Pass $30 that's 250
a month that is literally one beverage a
month again I think you can manage that
so that's what I mean I'm with you it's
like nothing's it they how many people
as I said like 500 to a thousand people
breaking their butt like lives to make
these amazing games they deserve to be
some like we deserve worse the video
game business so I mean shout out to all
listen I I feel more he's like speaking
for myself I didn't get the season pass
and I'm not interested in Christmas sir
so it's difficult for me especially all
the games coming out this fall to
justify playing it and I get that all I
would say is for the people on the fence
I think this is substantial
I think forsaking is substantial this is
almost like a rewrite of the game right
I would tell those people hey if you're
interested just touch the forsaken right
don't get the season pass let them prove
to you subsequently that they're gonna
continue to deliver that level of
quality you know I'm saying I think a
lot of reason wildly the people were
burnt is because let's be honest testing
to had a good start people Dovan Andy we
all bought the season pass kind of
expansion pass blind lately you know we
don't it you know it's you know whatever
whether it be us Osiris in warm and then
when Osiris hit it was so bad I get that
that's all I would say just hold off at
that point let them continue to prove
themselves each time I think you
probably safer at that that point but a
people who remember yeah and I mean
that's kind of hard things like some
people you've got division to doing a
free year of content you've got an
annual pass here and it's like alright
well when we get done with those two
years I want to compare those two years
of content not see like how much do you
get for free anyway we're gonna get from
seasons and things like that and then
how much do you get on top right so
that's what I was like when we get done
you're nearing is the extra $30 gonna be
worth it in my mind probably but we'll
see what like stuff like division anthem
do as well hey but yeah basically for
slow-mo I mean for anybody in that
nature especially do you just bought d2
nor like yeah didn't do it honestly just
wait just wait
of Davitt you'll have destiny too
forsaken complete year one package
whatever probably for like 60 bucks to
wrap everything up yeah maybe so you
might do a deal where the season passes
like you know 90 with the digital looks
like full there's gonna be some option
out there to wrap everything previously
up in a package for discount from what
it was and you'll be fine I think I
agree by the way shadow to this picture
right here this looks awesome but like
it looks amazing
five as you work to make changes to the
game what are the most challenging they
actually said stuff like triumphs and
the collections basically there's like a
gazillion things in this game and we
know that but trying to track them all
and keep them in one place and do all
that stuff as they wanted to do not an
easy thing to do so I was actually kind
of an interesting answer I thought for
that one mm-hmm
so we talked about the weapon slots
already now for the annual pass they say
how is that gonna you know be a better
delivery method right so for one you buy
it or you don't you just either get it
all you're not missing half of it which
is you know make your decision on that
one but they said what they wanted to do
with most of the content and I think
this sort of people will be happier it's
more things for you to play yes not a
two-hour story yeah now there's still
gonna be some type of way for them to do
story right what escalation protocol
weapon quests co-op experiences new
things for players to earn more
catalysts more other things all that
stuff is what we all want anyway so yeah
if it's more of a focus on that I guess
I can't see it wrong I mean I'm not
saying that's the can still tell a story
if they build one up for d3 it may be
amazing but right now what they've got
right maybe this is an okay focus for
this I actually coming around on this
cuz at first when I first heard of dis
mentality they were doing this I was a
little nervous because I was wondering
if the law is gonna suffer by the end of
the day let's be real and this is why
she had opted to do it again we were
talking about why war - was - started to
change because yet the story and war
mine was okay you know I'm saying better
than cars messiahs I should say that but
at the end of the day you know what we
realize with these campaigns you know a
lot it's just one and done it's not
replayable content what are we coming
back for those Catholics
those faction rallies those new exotic
changes those new grinds the polaris
lands right they're realizing what the
destiny fan wants not only the grind the
secret and all these things to keep you
coming back and logging in every day and
I think that's what this season past
changed those into not that they're not
gonna take away from story but if you
invest so much in this story one aspect
of your game that's just a one-and-done
aspect and not doing the thing that
actually destiny players love that's
where they were losing the community and
I think this is a good way to do it and
if you're talking about this consistent
scheme of content now three drops you
know winter you're getting the spring
drink and you're gonna get the summer
that's what ultimately right we just
want more content that was propriety
when it had those droughts so you know
I'm opening my mind on this new approach
so we'll see how are they execute but I
mean this is like is there no story no I
mean or story characters these are
important it's just the way they're
gonna do them out so if it's like you
know audio clips during strikes like I
honestly somebody said it the other day
and I can't remember where I saw it
probably just be read its thread I miss
like voice intros two strikes immigrant
we got tired dude it was a you know I
used to know that we're like it it gave
a little context you know do stuff like
that
add a little touches and then with a
darker tone I'm good I'm good yeah so I
was like they're they're trying and
they've got their ways to do it so we
will see I guess as the year progresses
what's coming so is they is the thought
that you would have more regular space -
space seasons with content for all
players our intention is absolutely what
you're suggesting enough for seasons
throughout the year spread equally
spaced so we have both free content for
all players who play it like iron banner
clan seasons all that stuff and then the
annual pass for new activities like
black armor a Joker's wild they have
some weird names for those too
those videos expansion so weird name I
agree yeah I have no idea now are there
raid layers coming back yes boo I like
that though okay what if though so
disconnected what I build ties okay let
me say the dreaming city is large so
it's not just a ship and you start to
encounter what if like okay so there's
another like set of a tower or you know
there's an S and then realm like what if
it is still connected to that dreaming
city which it probably will be and
that's how the raid layers work like
it's still really into the making but
you want a completely new theme yeah
because you know why I listen I get what
you're saying yeah you know it's not
like like I still don't I'm just took me
why I don't like it cuz at the end of
the day when expansion Joker's wild
comes out though the story is gonna
shift towards whatever that new you know
antagonist is and did it in when you
have a rate layer then that involves you
going back to the original thing like I
don't want to be going back to the
awoken city the Dreaming city every
single turn like that that was the
problem in my opinion with on to start
off with the rail and with a Leviathan
it just was disconnected from war mind
and no sorry it just if they find a way
great maybe they find a way maybe they
like you I mean the whole in-game world
is gonna be dreaming see that's where
you're doing stuff all the time if they
just add additional things to the
Dreaming city give you a small story
that builds up into there then you have
a new encounter in the Dreaming stage
you know only as long as it narrative ly
connects yep do it I don't want no half
I don't want just to wake up and then is
it being on the map saying hey I gotta
go to the dream why what's the
connection but I need to have a
narrative connection that that's the
problem of I it in me I mean not
leviathans great I mean Ito of world's
inspire of stars this just disconnect I
don't even know who that dude is why is
he there you know like there's no week
to me I got no closure with the Cuyler
story but I don't know what the whole
thing is about can you
did you tell me what we were doing like
all I know is he would kill the robot
version I'm spoiler for anyone who
didn't do rain you know saying this is
like bro like what was the whole purpose
at least with when you have a singular
raid like taking King we for him we go
to your send it round you learn you know
I'm saying and then you know you comin
out wait and then it just a complete
story start we get middle and conclusion
I'm worried about rail is I said my boy
over there we'll see how it goes you
know try to be open-minded but I'm
already kind of like I was like but III
mean Leviathan was basically yeah there
was some crap to run around and
underneath and you're looking for that's
kind of like a tease I guess like as a
place to go have your secrets and stuff
but I mean basically was like a raid
just like anything else you'll go
through your different encounters they
just put him in a circle instead of a
line fine
but yeah that was kind of its own thing
and then we would go through what was it
we did curse of Osiris it was on Mercury
like and vex and then all of a sudden
we're back like those are so
disconnected I fully fully understand
you're like oh you're sitting like
you're right trying to wrap your intern
how the hell do these two connect
nothing like all of a sudden we got a
call from Calais and like feels now in
turn as we have an entire awoken fallen
infested world of the Dreaming city and
this is where it's gonna go so I mean
say the black armory is literally that
within the Dreaming city say there is a
black armory in there you open that
thing like there's a quest that builds
up through you go through the tangled
Shore you do a couple of missions maybe
you do them in Reverse that's how they
use their content but you go through
that and you're like okay now you go
into the Dreaming city again you're
going through here
your final boss fights here and then
your raid layers literally like the next
thing behind that door like if that's
the way they tie it in that way and in
action feels I can dig that and yeah it
not Eagle one that I'm okay with they
only like I need a phone call no exact
the thing that helps your argument if
with the dream cities that there they
use the terminology that involves hidden
content if they can evolve it and it
matically connects you know to these
next two experience because history
tends to show when a new expansion comes
out there's a new antagonist and then
there's a new you know protagonist that
you kind of help out that's generally
how destiny works like it was Osiris
with helping out then was Ana bring
whatever now like this new person all
the stuff it has to connect so we'll see
that's all so yeah it's like I mean I
have my worries about it but it's like
as they're building this whole world for
an in-game I could see how it's at least
gonna connect that it has a potential to
connect a lot better
it showed up at gaming for day that's
another point I'm saying like he said he
likes the rail is because they're
getting better than getting one rate of
year least you get up to three way like
content throughout the year the only
thing I disagree with that you informed
for today is that the Rey layers I was
out of Leviathan were many raids they
didn't have that length I didn't have
that that weight that a normal rate and
the my opinion should have they felt
like mini raids and I don't like mini
racing this is the thing that turned
addict off the raid guys don't like that
they want those full full experiences
they don't want to feel cheated so as
long as they do that I'm cool with it
being a real label you just have to have
that same level of quality and content
as a normal rate but outside of dark
below when have we ever gotten more than
one raid in the year um then we have we
had on Sigma J was its whole thing for
the full Jay King right so didn't have
one I guess they had no yeah which it
didn't right and then after taking King
was a year later for res Larry but he
gave me spring content or a house day I
was the great trial that was the Greeks
right yeah you're typically we've gotten
one rate a year so you've got an option
you can either have something of which
strikes which most people get you know
somewhat tired of or you have the option
of something of a more challenging
encounter something cool mechanics like
a mini raid is personally better than
nothing just now I hate the fact that
the stories didn't connect I mean even
if the fights were cool something said
Argos is one of the coolest fights
because of how it was done right which
which is fine but it's just your reason
to go there if they can have that
connect and they're still give us pieces
that like to the dream song and I hear
your argument you're making a good
argument and slo-moes killing it right
now cuz I've just he readily read my
mind what I was just about to say which
is which leads towards your argument for
why they probably can't is that let's be
honest raised a very complex thing there
is very difficult to develop that's six
people so that's probably what it isn't
from a dev respective is like hey you
know we need more time and probably you
know intent so that's probably with it
the collective decision it's like okay
let's make these small or kind of rates
if flown as they're good the mechanics
are good it connects narrative Lee I'm
with it but if I'm disconnected again if
it's like I'm finished with Osiris I
don't by the way go over here and do
this that it doesn't make any sense I'm
gonna have a problem but was it yeah so
triumphs those are been gonna be things
you're gonna have like collections and
triumphs basically you're gonna have a
triumph score just like grimoire score
and I saw so many comment be like man I
hate I miss like seeing newbies grandma
or score like fifty like fifteen hundred
and be like you ever played that much
have you and now like triumph score is
gonna be all those things that you do so
it's waiting things you accomplished
they're bringing that stuff back again
these are all things that were by the
time they got there in dr3 of dusty to
we're in there they're making a lot of
shifts and like I don't know this is and
this is why it's like forsaken feels
like when they got the right amount of
time to make something destiny to feels
like somehow they were in some crunch a
whole bunch of stuff got ripped out
something had to be completely redone
destiny to felt so rushed still to this
day like I don't I don't think it was
what they wanted to I think it's what
they had to roll yeah some of the
reports came out that that was case do
you agree with like sixteen months to
make the whole game and you're like yeah
so and again here we get to refreshing
the Hobby so we're talking about just
things they want you to do where the
saying when you finish your week yeah
you could log in on Tuesday and do
everything well now if your what if your
next week is now Friday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday and then
Friday reset up I got
some new or even if it's Saturday you
get a new one on the weekend if it's on
a four day rotation well that's going to
be kind of crazy now the raid is
supposed to be on a weekly rotation
which is fine
craps a lot to do a raid what it means a
daily cycle to work on upgrading so
they're kind of changing the director to
remember the bottom left corner you had
here I have miss that I like so you've
got more choice of what you want to do
which thank goodness I hope this is a
plop the story missions to wood you can
go pick strikes any strike is gonna be
on the map for you to be able to do it
daily daily heroic story missions so
that might be even like a daily
milestone like there's literally reason
to log in every day and every day that
was to be one ground everybody misses
you had that that bottom left corner get
your daily story you date you weekly you
nightfall everything was nice Cabana I
believe in this case even want to have
gambit down there like not ask that and
that and synergy and that streamline
thing that it makes it better we're
gonna see how this distinct slice but
I'm like the way that sounds like I
mentioned our podcast here along with
all those activities along with
flashpoint school they refresh every
four days raids on a weekly cycle daily
heroics individual strikes are
selectable so oh I think half of your
chats basically saying our IP life and
everything else you me and everybody
else so this is the only thing on my end
as like if I try and play and make
content I'm behind everybody but if I
try and just burn through and play then
I miss out on the content I probably
should be making so I metal lose-lose
either way but I yeah yeah first world
problems right I have too much of a game
to player can make videos too much
before we completely we I meant to do so
managing inventory and vault space if
you guys haven't heard now granted it's
up to you but basically this and from
February but they said for sure
basically anything since war mind
anything that was in your inventory as a
war mines launch has been documented
they have a stowed away they have it
stored so you can literally go into your
inventory delete those six or seven hand
cannons those old sidearms and crap that
you don't use and they're still gonna be
a record in your collections so that's
like year one mostly taken care of
so I can hold on to my better Devils and
three other weapons and delete the rest
basically pretty much never touch the up
the server is a bungee unique snap
system yeah but I did some good stuff
just yet no no like my Betty Devil's
mind
nameless midnight that no you don't
abort the crash kind of a thing to like
if you have a specific masterwork I feel
like you might have to keep it yeah
that's a good point - I'm definitely
other Tracking's those Liam Ashe works I
think might be yeah I mean I guess you
probably just have to pull it back out
and use it cores to turn it back into
one so yeah I think or what we'll say if
you got a master or do you like don't
get rid of that yeah but I mean it's
gonna track basically everything from
shaders they basically sound like a
space between the podcast and the
questions thank God and you can just
pull them out put them on whatever you
want nope that you got a storm like a
you know I'm saying panicking that's
what I'm talking about huge huge deal
yeah it's literally just a currency to
do I mean so that's where it's like one
of those system things as I said before
it's like maybe you have to have some
type of consumable that you like that is
used up in the applying of it or the
fact that you don't have to hold on to
all of them and I can delete half the
ones I don't mash it or deletes gonna be
a quick thing to it's like yeah that's
gonna be so much better so that's gonna
be better you're gonna have 500 slots so
take out the shaders take out your one
you're gonna have random rolls which may
give you more things to hold on to but
with 500 slots and all that other stuff
managed reasonably well I think we
should be in a reasonable spot as long
as you don't hoard every single option
for each gun exactly yeah
so that's actually feeling really good
mods are being overhauled they still
won't say much to bugging me we can I
don't know if it won't be done until
September 3rd and it just gets dumped in
a like day one patch honestly so they do
say because this is one I've been
wondering about a lot talking mods are
being overhauled and are recoverable
from dismantled legendary gear I like
that so they're not just mobs are the
players way of improving customizing
even beyond random roles there are fewer
mod
that are more interesting I really hope
they live up to that because we have a
hope now if you look through there's not
that many mods that are relatively
different now because I mean there's a
lot of like different things if there's
gonna be less mods than I see now then I
guess I kind of wonder if it's gonna be
like is it Ranger as a fire damaged or
who knows the fewer kind of worries me
because they don't have an exorbitant
amount now that are distinctly different
so I guess we'll have to see I don't
know the child is just as mixed on top
about mods you know I mean to me I don't
mind if they don't have the power
anymore I don't like that it's just a
number I mean just a number you know I'm
saying at the other day it like I put a
check to it I hate it know how hard the
kinetic one was to get to oh my god you
literally have to break down enough
Purple's so you have those and then he
go there you make weapon mods that's the
only way to get them I got literally one
or two randomly from all my hours of
games but yeah on the other side like it
I'm honestly happy that puttan
power numbers going away because if I
was say 375 but it's due to mods and I
get a 372 to drop it feels unsatisfying
yes just in my head it's lower than I
know it's bouncing up my base level and
all that craps in there it just didn't
feel good and that was psychologically
unrewarding so I mean if they're taking
that away so now if anything even if
it's a small increment it's still above
my level that will feel better every
time so that's just a mental thing they
have fewer conditions that limit what
class or weapon type so it's just
overall general things like range you
know if it's gonna be grenade recharge
time it's non class it's not item it's
not any of its justice it just use it
here yep pick your mods um so that's I
mean they have a special one so
increased hipfire or airborne accuracy
jasmine to the sky finally I can take
that out the vault and actually have
some accuracy let's go yeah but I mean
what if you had Interac yura see on your
weapon and then you also throw
interactor I say on a couple piece of
armor yeah really boost and that's what
you play style is from the
you know builds yes which is what
destiny is sorely lacking so yeah that's
what I'm with this oh yeah so triumphs
that's gonna be a record book I'm trying
to see what else
I'm site I've read this multiple times
but as you look at him like I forget
where we are but there's gonna be
different lower segments to find hidden
chests in the SolarCity that type of
stuff is coming back which is really
really really huge so your triumphs are
individually locked each triumph
contributes to a triumph score so I grew
more scores we're talking about that
stuff is back and this just looks cool
this looks like a big centerfold here
but this looks like a big I think this
is one of the gambit arenas if I
remember right yeah this is a game it
we've talked about before honestly
that's gonna be one of the modes that
like I've only heard positive things
about nothing more positive and I played
it it's fantastic because those guys
that don't like the crucible are gonna
love this mode there's no pressure you
can do you say you just send one guy in
to the portal if you want to do the pvp
portion so much fun strategy's gonna be
good this is a really cool mode yeah I
just have to wait till lunch because I'm
not going to guarding either way I mean
honestly for me it'll be fresh so that
it'll be fun but people can other
strategies already you'll be fine play
everything so look at this picture like
if as I said I mean this could be
concept art but the scale of the door
just the size of things that it's in
here so they actually talk about a new
PvP mode as well I guess we are gonna
cover the whole damn article sorry guys
we like long point one point I'll say
that much adder it is like yep it's two
hours plus already Bungie has some big
announcements for PvP so they're gonna
evolve the crucible at a faster pace
means react more quickly than we could
in the past so they've got different
things in place for systems where they
can make changes quicker also they've
got new a new mode called breakthrough
it's in the competitive pay list and you
start each round both teams attempts you
control a breaker which allows you to
hack the enemy
once you control the breaker it can't be
recaptured and one team goes on the
offensive one team goes then defensive
so it's like a double objective you got
to get the first one but then if you
miss that one fall back and defend and
then you can hold them off and maybe
hold it out for time so gonna be
interesting
I mean competitive doesn't have a big
draw for me still just because I feel
like on PC I'm gonna be so sweaty anyway
you know with glory being in there in
the competitive list actually might get
back in there gotta get some glory in
man is it's fun but I gotta recommend
like you got to have a team room you got
to know I know don't solo out you kill
you know I was like man it was even pyro
he picked up like I think he picked up
one at Best Buy and I was just like
playing on a plane on his laptop before
is like it but not great now away from
my clinic Ross play for destiny that's
what we do as a recent week the weeks
have a test at forsaken will arrive it
at a time in which competitors like
anthem in Division two will be nipping
at its heels it's safe to say dusty two
needs a big win the second has the
makings of a phenomenally absorbing and
longtail gaming experience now I just
have to wait to see if all the pieces
can fit together I mean and that says
the wraps are well perfect and we talked
about this on last ILP when you guessed
with a without what we had Eric's when a
show Eric's yeah awesome guy and that's
what we taught it was like the division
versus destiny versus you know anthem
and you know they have this this is so
critical for me cuz if this doesn't this
is not successful you know you know
there is no is the committee lead-up to
any competition like this has to hit so
there's tons of stuff to do like me and
you've talked offline when you know for
say February March when these guys hit
obviously it won't be much content from
guessing at that point let them drop let
that marinate then they come back with a
spring update and hopefully you know I'm
saying they continue what they've been
doing so we'll see this is definitely
critical time but from what we're seeing
what we're reading
sounds to be real positively really in
the right direction and it's probably
the most I've been excited and eighty
point I mean I'm saying
during the destiny to life cycle yeah I
mean you also got to things like I mean
one of their expansion is gonna fall
dead in the middle of the heat yes as if
you go even spacing it's December fourth
after September March fourth
that's smack between both of them I
think they're gonna do April I think
it's it because I remember when you got
a good then you jump to June like if
they want even spacing you can't wait
yeah one for then do one to like they
may just have to stick with theirs and
see where it falls you see where fall
out yeah that's a good point
so now Karen so this is story so one
more piece we do in a cover for you guys
that I can still with us
God who's a big article to drop now
story spoiler ish warning come on if you
ain't okay dad come on now no no not
even that I'm just saying these are most
of the campaign yes
from what I gather there's probably
gonna be a mission or two of an
introduction what goes on with kaydessa
prison and all that yes correct the
ending is a culmination of if you want
to guess that you probably can I won't
say it your middle or the Barons yes so
they're gonna either be their own
adventures or these things and most of
them are going to be kind of pick your
own choose your own adventure type and
then I think maybe the last couple are
gonna culminate towards the end so
there's like an intro the middles got
like six and then probably like a final
three or four to finish up the story so
what if you do the math on that one even
as an adventure with some voice over
some story things like that that's still
at least one to get you going six in the
middle and then at least two or three
more that's like that's a longer at
least set of activities that we
typically get than most stories so it's
a lot to do mm-hmm yeah it's a ton to do
time to do did Google not update for you
just isn't showing it right now I don't
know why sure oh no you're good my
youtube fine yeah
yep mine somehow got lost okay so there
are eight barons now these the guys we
fight
amethyst by the way first off they're
not short these are some totally boys
it's a big boys so who are they they're
once a hodgepodge of lowly dregs cast
out from the upstart House of exile and
between all the craziness that has
happened between you know apparently
being real woken and turning into scorn
and all the craziness like that they are
nuts so when you come in all these guys
have their own mechanic to them their
separate have their own mechanics that
have their own tweaks to them I mean
they talked about it in the viaduct one
of them was a sniper for example
long-range sight lines you're gonna have
some like snipers trying to pick you off
as you go through the adventure it's
gonna be very specific in that each
one's gonna have a theme to it yeah like
they described this which was so dope
like a Western and it was kind of like
you know like the classic western
revenge story they got our boy we got
our list these are the domes nothing and
we gotta go I won't like that is so like
narrative Lee fun to me you don't say
like that old western revenge story
they're like let's go it's Charlie doing
like it's like the berries of the
Cowboys it dudes they're like you gotta
go through them they're like I'm super
high and what I like and this I'm gonna
I'm gonna Long Point and it for a second
all right no is that remember how you
you were counting that you like hog I
don't know them telling us about canine
early but this is like for the people
who'd knock around them playing destiny
what I see is this is the motivator they
like okay you know say like people are
like oldrin got to get it I'm seeing the
narrative I'm seeing people like really
emotionally I'm saying about picking the
game walk just to do this that's why I
think yeah it may be a little cheap to
get there to pay off the people in but
the cool part about it why I still like
to think that it is that this is not end
game this is story so we still got a
deeper plot to unravel with Aldrin and
all his other stuff and hopefully
whatever you know saying so I'm so man I
think this was
good core normally I'm with you and I
would say hey save the arm decay death
you know as a secret for people who pick
it up but then I could also see the
flipside what people say when they
didn't say that Kay dies and you pick it
up my all Bunji just something so cheap
you gotta you gotta get in the word gets
out you know kind of thing
so I can see both sides so but I still
like this way that they doing it just me
okay I mean I can't argue with the fact
that it's probably working mine's more
just the fact that like if I was going
through and didn't expect it I'll be
like hey it's the per se caen you got
some tones to it like the what like what
is it
oh that first mission you're like huh
and just like that gut wrenching moment
like oh and you could just the weight of
it I just feel like there would be more
but either way I'm still gonna play it
I'm still gonna play the crap out of it
so they talk about they've got eight of
them so the phonetic I'm not gonna say
the name thick rolling sounds like
fickle yeah so leader of the barons and
the dark corrupted evolution of the e
Elk City known as the scorned so second
only to the prince older and saw so he's
second to older and yeah he's like your
second last mission it sounds like
probably probably so as an evolution of
the Fallen and a final manifestation of
what they were always meant to be and
you can literally see like we're in a
sniper rifle in the dudes big like oh
he's not messing around
it's real out here see he's probably
using see what he's hitting them with
yeah they've got probably a Golden Gun
coming at him that's a lot of damage
into what looks like a pretty big head
is the idea absolutely the hunt is on
man we got to get them yep now I can't
tell do you think this is actually in
the Dreaming setting or the tangled
Shore to the campaign
it looks like the Dreaming city it looks
like what it would be what if this is
the tangled sure maybe this is a weird
part of it possibly yeah I'm very see
what is gonna go uh-huh
so then we've got the machinist mm-hmm
second in command to the fidelity Cates
quote underneath the fanatic I think
yeah I think they had like
I don't like this not one bit he's a
delete a believer to the core and
they're the toughest to put yeah we
gotta put this in context these are guys
Cade already captured before right they
so they have motivation with Aldrin to
do this to gate because from my
understanding he just um you know I'm
saying like he originally defeated these
guys with another group he had his team
that's anakata got them in a prison so
now that the Odin's bust these guys out
they kind of have a revenge on kick he's
like the police officer and now they got
a hold of him yeah it's like they got
out and now everyone's after the sheriff
continue oh the Machinists second in
command to the fanatic and his most
ardent follower expert in munitions
weapon crafting and in charge of a siege
on the redacted
she-she interesting she's an insatiable
thief and hoarder with a terrifying
arsenal and you see here big gun so like
the like pretty large and whatever's on
her back between like a small
flamethrower
yeah just looking you switching over
from like I'm just watching the fight
the gifts to see them switch ammo
actually this looks like an old build
yes if you look it's like power energy
and kinetic this is a little like old
build before all that stuff started that
means good point so that's interesting
oh there's no quote on this one yeah I
think this looks cool like look at the
head yeah it's ridiculous particle
effects she gonna be a problem yeah this
is like the straight-up an acolyte mmm
you gotta leave this order - yeah but
that's straight-up an acolyte yeah so
the Mindbender praxis is the brain a mad
genius who has been changed by his
research into the hive and their dark
religion has somehow found a means of
exercising control over - so like a
necromancing yes late literally but
never got a little bit raising the dead
but yeah but look at like scale of size
on this guy here watching this little
gift as you run up
be like what the holy crap to do to
let's go down yeah okay so watch this
thing it says holiday exiled and then it
says ascendant plain wonder like how
he's dipping in and out that's but
that's what girls like you don't get to
the dreaming city until you finish the
campaign these guys are in the campaign
I'm pretty sure yeah oh that's where I'm
like utterly confused as to where all
this craps going on
yeah they keeping stuff from us they
definitely come so mastermind the
greatest CRO highest trip what is this
oh I was obsession with the high of all
this stuff is going on um never heard of
a mind bender surprise that's just how
he likes the exit and there's one thing
I believe is one bit of an ass thing
with him was weird I believe like God
doesn't talk or something like that was
one of them maybe I got this one
confused the whole thing yeah it's like
you're you're intrigued we'll take a
look so as a starving runty little
dragged the Mindbender fell into the
moon's Hellmouth you never spoken an
intangible word since but his mind and I
was domain changed him gave him a
lifelong obsession after years of study
found a way to carve a throne world of
his own horse and in her own here's the
part read the first list all utility
read the first bullet point this one is
this one resonated with me so mastermind
yes the great crow heist trapped a
brainwashed Prince alterans crows
holding them to feed misinformation and
fuel attention between earth and the
reef hey could be some motivation
biologist acting crazy
yeah but he also feels like you should
be higher up in the pecking order if
he's like a mastermind which is odd just
like the evil genius scientist of the
overlord yes yes now the trickster I'll
warn anybody listening to this right now
when you go do your trickster adventure
thanks to the game inform article be
weary because you're probably gonna
explode pretty early on there's a trap
if you watch Star Wars it's a trap and
it's for real we're mostly war I see an
opportunity for a left it's literally
he's gonna mess with you so a silver
tongue manipulator and a con artist with
a high
piñon of herself the trickster I didn't
hurt I don't know quite why that's
throwing me off I don't picture that
many female high pollen but maybe I'm
totally wrong
I don't think we've seen many the
trickster has a penchant for deadly
sleight of hand and prefers to work
behind the scenes when it comes to the
Barons operations she does all she can
to stay out of sight and is known for
duping others into doing their dirty
work on this one yeah just watch your
step in here yeah it looks like they're
melting there right now but damage there
the amethyst highest massacre who raid
the Queen's mines the tricks are
orchestrated a clever ploy that pitted
12 teams of bounty hunters against one
another to create a subterfuge all
should clear out the mine for herself
hmm whatever you do don't trust anything
she touches I promise you it'll bite I
like a cage that was bloody this one
look old man the hangman yeah bang maze
like to do talk about likes dough rexis
the scathed the ghost that tight old man
so the silence a silence a dust known
first pension for docking and tearing
ether generators from from the core it
was bear his obsession with torturing
servitors is unprecedented rate of the
LED cabin lxd Alexa T I guess yeah yeah
but I guess that's the scorn mm-hmm but
yeah his lantern and stuff like that
looks just bananas no one knows what the
hangman was abandoned at birth some say
his parentage looked into his eyes and
knew something knew what it would become
that's like I'm looking at the
Antichrist Wonder Woman
others say the cruel deed sealed his
fate the hangman doesn't just kill the
victims he hurts them he has a specific
hatred for servitors the Fallen machines
created in the travelers image who
enforced the Fallen hierarchies by
deciding who eats and who doesn't he's
physical rejection of the owl scheme
oops to me what I'm gonna get this I
want somebody on say the next time oh
yeah that works yeah tradition is
ultimately what drew him into the
fanatics inner circle but whether it's
for brief or statistics opportunity has
yet to be determined
yes that that Lance in row and
land that very wall that's insane and
he's just running right through it like
okay and he's a very aggressive male a
stout is gonna be lit one he likes it
too much he likes it if you torture big
claws too much three woods we got X we
got X the Mad Bomber I love how he has
like an ammo clip of her nades around
that is Scooby panicked unikz two
fingers because he blew one of them off
I'm sure the detonator a bombastic
thrill-seeker for whom self-preservation
is an afterthought take throws known as
the Mad Bomber is willing to blow an
entire location to smithereens just to
kill his target
well it sounds about right yeah crazy
yeah big lunatic look we all like movies
they need a goon they already got they
think this is the street grooming and
kids like look we all like blowing stuff
up but there's a line a line let's get
across a long time ago the rifleman this
is the one I'm looking for
Oh straight-up sniper fight right next
to them by the way a little particle
effects on him I don't know what it is
but I want I want that I want that
ornament for all my armor and I'm sold
I'll buy the annual babe what if we get
it whatever we get up easily do we each
will we defeat that be kinda badass
mm-hmm the rifleman right here at the
Phantom pier the blind an all-seeing
sniper who watches his brothers barons
backs the rifleman keeps his targets at
a distance plays really dirty and never
misses his shots brilliant cold and
patient and more than more than one of
the Rifleman's notches as a guardians
ghost ooh that's it right home and hold
on I'm trying to figure out watch the
gift and watch the wall of fire that
like flames up towards him
what the hell is that a what's that I
don't know I'm kind of wondering what
that is because I mean if it's something
like in the world now in the order that
you probably want to fight this guy like
lore like at least within the lore I
feel like you should have to fight him
first
otherwise he's just gonna kill you
anybody else like puzzles yeah he'd have
to be first so you can actually get to
the others because your snipers gonna
take you out before you get to the other
sure he's telling me protect the knees
on the floor your asses theoretically
just be kids keep your eyes open heads
down and your ghost close and this one
just looks kinda awesome to the writer
was actually unlike what's like a heavy
pike yah mix the Hoss yeah fix the ha
sobbing same anarchist biker and leader
of her own gang of Pike riders are they
all female I'm kind of there's a three
female fought the rider raises fields
and pollutes the air everywhere she and
her gang run she's a master mechanic
who's taken fall in heavy pike and made
it better much much better and as it
looks like a giant flaming yet even here
Leah I'm look at this you try it you're
like on your Sparrow trying to chase her
down so this would be like a sparrow
race yeah fire and not explode whoo this
will be the point where if you have
these sparrows that recharge like summon
back quicker after they explode that's
gonna be your one debris yeah I can see
this from being frustrating I guess you
just won't be an annoying yeah well
looks like you're on a heavy pike cuz
you've moved up like it's not a sparrow
so you'll be doing something fighting or
maybe it's just the area but yeah it's
definitely see that one being
interesting decay got anything on the
writer I paid good money to watch the
race between Marcus and this one who's
Marcus I don't know how you say like
Amanda is I mean there's eight very very
different fights and honestly like what
are your story machines usually run
through this mind pathway go to the end
shoot this orange bar you're done like
this is really cool and if I want to go
back and play the story missions again
and there's a daily or oak and it's one
of these that's actually gonna be fun
that's gonna be fun yeah like that's
going for like and again people are
gonna want that satisfaction of marking
these bearings off that list cuz the
emotional connection the way they took
part of K cuz you remember that
cinematic out the Elgin but the bottom
eight barons walk right over like yes
they was very
very sad very solemn you know say like
this is this this is a revenge or
western baby it's on its own so that's
that's like all of them so few different
pictures of them they all have their
uniqueness I don't I didn't see this one
up top
what's this yeah like I mean so I'm
gonna scroll or a quick writer right
movin little Matt Bomer Oh
hangman name trickster
Mindbender machinist and fanatic but at
it in the crap is this yeah keep going
here I'm looking at that YouTube things
little by little that's the hangman yeah
yeah that's dead let's do cuz he's got
the lantern he may be able to contort
and do something with it that's oh okay
that makes a little more sense it was
right will the lanta cuz I remember them
saying he's a melee character that's him
as yeah but that thing looks like all of
a sudden it's got like you know ten-foot
chains on fire yes oh it just got much
more like he's whipping people yeah
ripping on fire chains so that looks
like The Machinist cuz you just kind of
up on his back with all of his guns yeah
that's the same guy same area that's but
you know bomber just chunk and stuff at
you for days yeah that's just a solid
picture I like that look of the cross
the Fallen - I like glory trickster guy
put this in a raid not have been good
like did that's the fact that this is
all this a bit of camp age is really
really cool so take all of this and then
know that the rate is the biggest one
they've ever done that's what I'm saying
like how crazy is this yeah League I got
a theory though hey everything's on the
table name
because they thought but they did say
didn't correct me from worry
didn't they say that the raid will be
boss heavy yeah they said was more
bosses than anyone and taking King at
four so I'm curious to see you know
saying if from these guys like you come
is it fallen is it awoken is it taken
versions of these guys like I'm so
confused because then I'm hearing dragon
so I don't know what's good like it's so
much mystery with what the actual raids
gonna be about yeah the big thing in the
article is the fact that like your time
with Aldrin is basically leading to the
fact that there is a bigger evil at play
right so the things like does the
campaign and with the band like where
does Holdren fitting in what sequence
right does he fit at the rave like I
don't notice it I can't like the dude
say like about mine that's what's so
cool about it all is like he said could
it be the barons would it be all new
bosses it's so much going on right now
cuz there's still a huge part we don't
know about with the rave I get so much
and we still got the mystery of the
Queen what's gonna happen is all during
the boss like what then we hear about a
dragon poisoning city it's so much going
on right now yeah this is a bit of it
there's one point and this is again
heads up spoilers ending this is the
culmination of the campaign is Aldrin
okay so although that's why I was like
opening Barron's final couple Barron's
Aldrin leading into the Dreaming city
all of this is before the Dreaming city
that's a lot of crap a lot of content
and then the Dreaming city is its own
thing and then who knows what the big
evil isn't there is it something you
awaken from the ascendant realm is it
indeed evolution of the Dreaming city
every two or three weeks
yeah that's gonna rotate like I don't
even so yeah late thing so many people
forget and we probably said this before
video games used to be more than $60
they're the cheapest thing that still
exists
yeah like they're one of the cheapest
forms of entertainment for the time that
you get out of them and for $60 for
there's a reason they have to do an
annual pass because honestly they
probably shouldn't charge $100 for this
game listen man there's a lot of content
that's all I could say no one can say
that they same content bro yeah no this
is so much a change the world lake and
just the fact that it's like campaign
streaming City all of that changing the
puzzles the hype overload
yeah I mean dado had his info Splosion
video you've got like I could go through
I mean I'm glad we're doing this like if
I tried to trim this thing down and
still be half hour talking at you guys
like trying to cope with all the things
and read through the points but there's
there's a really good reddit thread out
there if you follow me on Twitter I
posted recently you can look through
some of those it kind of culminates all
this stuff into bullet points which is
nice yeah but there's so so much so much
man
so much exciting times max yeah you're
less than two months away
mm-hmm we don't even have the summer
solstice yet we still do and we still
get updates covered yeah we still got
this which is gonna be a way to get
armor up to 400 so there's and that's
not rating it doesn't sound like it's
something all of those things a lot to
know the what is nice y'all if you've
been away - what is it starting to get
yeah I'd start I'd start leveling up a
little bit so you're ready for forsaken
because by the time it comes even get to
that soft cap Bri I don't know yeah
either way but they're working on all
that stuff like I'm thinking some things
are gonna be all the way down to the
wire for like a day one patch yeah so
it's no no I'm just like thinking about
everything and I'm just like after
everything we just said I'm like
dumbfounded I'm like there's so much
yeah I don't even know so I think that's
probably a reasonable place to start
trying to wrap this thing up matters
yeah girl feels like I know you gotta
sleep but you got anything else you want
to look for shayzon forsaken call me she
trying to be objective but I can't just
on what they talked about alone without
any of the secrets without any of the
evolution of the you know the dreaming
city without any information about the
rain without any information about you
know all these other molds which sorts
beginning in detail just the story alone
of Kade and the Barons to me is worth
$30 right so you're talking all that
ain't talking gambit mode you know and
narrative Lee the tone is dark
everything sounds great
I'm hype man it's it's very promising
you know it feels like this thing is
fully turned around and um I should say
fully turn around but you know on the
right path and um listen this this game
form did a fantastic job I think and one
thing I like again for the people who
are on the fence right
no let that family flag don't but look I
just don't listen we've all we've been
burned before you know saying and the
reason why I'm keeping it in dude is
that you know dusty - did launch -
positive vibes you know I'm saying it
did launched a very positive but we
clean it it just that when we got
beneath the surface be like damn it's
not enough depth this don't sound like
that
right this don't sound like any this
sounds like depth upon depth upon depth
you know I'm saying and I think we're
gonna be rocking for a long time I mean
just or scale alone is saying you know
this thing is NASA side of messes right
that that one space that we gotta unlock
so to speak right correct movin on am I
correct with that for which one from the
the local city that we unlock isn't that
the size of like necess what they're
saying yeah that's insane
so yeah like this this is the time this
is it's time to come back this is this
is the time to see what's going on very
promising I'm high
let's go let's do it in the subclasses
like we talked about that like it's so
much it's like
information over like nine you know
that's in theory and my opinion yeah
I've been cool to see a new complete
subclass
but nine variations of playstyles
you can't there's no way you can say
this doesn't justify the price so again
shout out to you know dog [ __ ] [ __ ] wolf
you know we're gonna see new I'm saying
farmers um you know how to handle the
you know the curse of Osiris and warm
and stuff you know but again just
forsaken only Wow Wow
I'm very high alright what's your
feeling when it meant before you ran
outside of everything you just said it's
just like I mean for me the idea the
raid is the ending city like that's a
big thing for certain people you've got
the weapon system coming back that is
gonna be a culmination of a variety and
an evolution of what people want and you
get to pick your battles
you've got the director changing up so
you can pick your strikes you've got
your highly heroics you've got your
gambit which is its own mode which is
not even hardly in this article with
matchmaking with men well yeah with
matchmaking for sure but it's just like
that's its additional thing that
everybody already loves yeah so take all
of those pieces mm-hmm
yeah I'm gonna be playing this a lot
like so much but honestly just remember
if you like the game I hope you all
enjoy it and I think this is a good this
is the best time to come back that I've
probably ever been able to tell anyone
this is the time forsaking get that
complete package now if you want to skip
the Annual Pass it's still gonna be
there waiting for you but if you have
that $60 package let us everything from
b1 and you're just ready to go it's
still worth $60 without a doubt in my
mind the effects pick that up if you're
missing the expansions if it's 40 it's
absolute and just enjoy every moment of
it don't rush through it as much as
sometimes we do take in everything
they're still gonna be a buttload of
stuff to find out there and just embrace
everything late and it secrets will
evolve things will be undiscovered you
know it's it's gonna be more things that
peel the layer by layer they're
designing it in such a way that content
is continually gonna be added and
discover
and that is also super exciting because
that's what destinies to be chose to be
about that that that sense of discovery
that mystery and I like the tone the
tone is dark they say one thing that
they only also forgot to say is that
narrative Lee they said they don't want
this to be about every five minutes
the ghost is cracking a one-liner you
know saying or there's gonna be comment
leaf or like this is a serious story for
the most part yeah there's gonna be some
humor in certain parts but I already
like the mindset you know and I'm saying
like don't don't move let's do it let's
get on this I already took off work so
you already know I'm about take some
more about a whole week yeah you might
need along you might have to do like
every every other four days or something
everybody said everything else
I got a blaze I'm ready ready
in the books yeah thank you guys for
sticking with those two hours before
this is our longest one yet I knew it
was gonna be huge computer it was
massive but all you guys in chat
thanking you for tuning out to now
tuning in don't sue now oh good I'm so
delirious man at this point yeah so
honestly I can't wait keep sticking with
us guys you've been with us this long
it's gonna be a lot even more fun stuff
to talk about our days when we take off
and do our podcast whether whatever's
going on when that happens yeah we're
gonna have some fun stuff to talk about
when this thing comes out absolutely man
I'm gonna go hang up my wife we're gonna
do our stuff for birthday for her happy
birthday
yeah mines are in the cornerstone - are
your code updates yes all right guys
yeah but I pre appreciate do be allowed
to do did they shout to the chat
everybody huh we went long man and like
I said we just definitely excited really
appreciate you guys sticking with it
real fun as far as the for me obviously
you know it's at Lord God made on
Twitter all that good stuff on Sunday is
the Lord's Day we actually have our
patreon guests this week so we keep it
in light keep it fun
it'll be fine we'll actually uh talks
what's going on in gaming have some
folks with it so please check that out
on the inner circle Network that's gonna
be at 1:00 p.m. Eastern and obviously
you know flashpoint will be returned
Friday morning looking like this that's
kind of like our jam for right now
schedule eyes right brought a moody sort
of looking like seems to be Freddy's
right now if something changes we'll let
you guys know but if it's not Friday and
work changes up you know it might be
like Thursday night or something or
evening we'll see where we can squeeze
it in but yeah we will find ways to make
it work so we'll keep it going even if
we gotta shift dates or we crazy they
shout to to do we gotta get piccolo we
got it we got a do a flashpoint in tower
talk at something we gotta figure these
schedules out do you guys want a good
ship to man I really like what you got
very passionate destiny guys we got to
do an episode together man it will be so
much fun we gotta figure this schedule
out ready yeah no yeah for me you guys
know it's Twitter Avant is twitch TV if
you guys are checking in life thank you
it's Avant is there as well it's easy
nobody else got a bond too so that one's
mine and insane on YouTube that's me
again all the all the followers likes
all that good stuff always helps us out
so thank you guys just even for tuning
in for this long as dedication right
there so and yeah lots to look forward
to and I'm I'm on the hype train even
though I'm I gotta try and make sure it
doesn't go too fast there we go thank
you guys have yourselves a good morning
enjoy your weekend and we'll see you
soon
peace